what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
um today we are going to be talking
about last night's episode of fresh and
fit they had snico Destiny and Rolo
tomasi called in and honestly it was
probably one of the best pieces of
content that I have seen in a long time
but today I did bring a friend with me
introduce yourself to the people hello
my name is yusra I'm 26 years old and
I'm here with pearl I'm very excited to
react to the last episode of fresh and
fit let's see what they have and just to
clarify for the people you've been on
the show right yes and you weren't
traumatized I mean well this show is is
is great but not from like traumatizing
point of view no I enjoyed it no no
trauma I just wanted to make sure I
wanted to double check okay so I want to
give you a little back story all right
so actually let me pull up the Tweet
first one second okay
um
all right we're gonna go to Twitter can
we pull up the the video I just want to
show her the people on screen
um so there is a guy named Rolo
um roll out I forgot I can't show you
the Tweet
um named Rolo tomasi and he basically
put out a tweet that was talking about
the the quickest way to become a high
value man
um and this sparked a lot of debate
because not everybody has the same
definition of a high value man what you
may think is a high value man is
different than from what I may think of
a high value man and one of the things
he put in there was to get a vasectomy
now the way I understood it was that he
was just saying this is the quickest way
not the best way to do it does that make
sense yes that's how but other people
were saying you shouldn't say that
because you're influencing people to go
do that and you don't know if it's
reversible
Etc does that make sense exactly I mean
you cannot say something general because
you have an audience so you have to be
very careful and specific about what you
say so I can't understand where the
debate comes from but I'm looking
forward for the answer so I can see what
happens okay so guy on the right that's
the guy who had the Tweet okay uh left
is the show okay okay so uh we're gonna
start it they have a clip in the
beginning that's of later part in the
debate but okay
for just five seconds okay there's no
joke here but I don't even know what the
red pill idea okay so there's the Tweet
can you can you read that blessing
this is the the tweet I just want to
make sure
yeah uh the quickest path to becoming a
high volume man
uh the first one do not get married
avoid or hit another thing family
creation family creation uh Vector to me
live consistently eliminate all
sedations learn game and networking play
to your strength build wealth resist
easing up on your focus
and this was a reply to Richard V Reeves
Okay so he is going to explain what he
meant in this okay high value man is is
it just being rich like what's the point
of having all this money and not having
a family what is a high value man it's a
first part of the Tweet what does that
mean you tell me what a high value man
is
it doesn't matter what
what says a high value man because it's
your Tweet douche nozzles like yourself
to have this conversation in the first
place
douche nozzles yes you guys are idiots
why you guys come in here from Twitter
is a high value man let's take for do I
think he is I don't think he's a high
value
he owns his own business it's like one
of the most successful media Platforms
in the world he's married and young
sweetheart right right you know who else
is not a high value guy Elon Musk let's
see uh who else uh Jeff Bezos yeah go
back to Twitch that's some advice
yup this is the you see the div we're
gonna we're gonna put it from the
beginning though this is a bit of a
longer clip so I'm gonna try to let it
play for a bit okay so I'm I'm not
trying to not let the commentary come in
I just want to make sure we watch it
that's really nice
your boys here roller tomasi shots
[Music]
he's always in the chat
he's probably doing his hair right now
he's our homie man uh does he just it's
not just your street like I see him in
every every show I go on just dude's
like are you always online
he is he is in a lot of chats I won't
lie to you
yeah that man is in the chat a lot but
you know what I mean he is online then
yeah yeah yeah
so it's hard sometimes you want to put a
comment in the chat you can you guys can
put a comment in the chat are you
serious bro about you Damon yeah Pearl
show everything which is a bit Rolo of
course I would he would body you man
okay all right
let him do it you know bro
Destiny just sends his weak oh F girls
to debate me because he's too scared to
come to Vegas and sit across the same
for me offer has been open since
November damn if he wants to debate me
on somebody else's pockets that's fine
but I'm not gonna go and like dig this
guy [__] Lazarus from the underworld
or try to resurrect his career that's
not my job I'll be here next week okay
wait is he talking about we did Rolos
Destiny why did you clip it like this do
you see I'm assuming Rolo sent that
tweet wait so I don't understand why
wouldn't he go to his podcast
oh he feels like he's bigger than Rolo
is that what he's saying
all right okay open since November damn
if he wants to debate me on somebody
else's pockets that's fine but I'm not
gonna go and like dig this guy [__]
Lazarus from the underworld to try to
resurrect his career that's not my job
I'll be here next week okay
yeah he doesn't agree him oh yeah he's
saying you're not irrelevant you're not
relevant enough
okay
I do understand that thought though
because you know like him or hate him
Destiny is like everybody do you know
Destiny maybe you don't ah she doesn't
uh a lot of people do know who Destiny
is like even when he was on our show
like he the views went up a lot so you
kind of do have to be specific when
you're at a certain level of like
picking who you want to debate with and
who because not everyone's worth your
your time right if they're not
resonating at the same level of like
mindset or even understanding it's just
like a wasting energy for uh for nothing
yeah but I do I would like to see it
though I would I do think it would be a
good debate so I hope they do it if he
wants to yeah and he should debate your
ass yeah okay great let's pull up brolo
sweet real quick because this has been a
point of contention uh which sneaks a
lot of things um we got it right there
so this was a sweet right it goes um and
this was from a week ago about a week
one week ago uh so the quickest path
the quickest path to becoming a high
value man number one don't get married
avoid family creation vasectomy in your
20s Life Lift consistently eliminate all
sedations learn game and networking play
tier strengths build wealth resist
easing up on your focus and and it's uh
the quickest path to becoming a high
value man
um and I know that you know snico had
some point of contention specifically
with number three which is get a
vasectomy in your 20s
um can I just ask why did he need eight
points did he like get contracted to
write all eight of these because like I
see some people here so like number two
avoid family creation number three the
second year 20s okay so this is how I
think of it
so when I think of a high value man
it's either money or influence comes
with it because like I I think they used
Gandhi as an example like would you
think Gandhi's a high value man he's
influential for sure yeah so like I
would think it's maybe money influence
um go ahead I would I would even include
uh social abilities yeah and uh even
Fitness yeah because they all relate to
being that high value men and that
definition is being a a person that
doesn't uh look or behave like the
others so you have to have all the
components that makes you stand up out
of the crowd so I actually think that
Fitness adds to being a high value man
but I don't think in order to initially
be high value you have to be in shape
because I think like it would be tough
for me to say like Bill Gates isn't a
high volume but you know that man is not
in shame of course but but like for
younger generations for example the one
that are willing to become a high value
man I would say definitely emphasize on
it yeah yeah but I I don't know
I
I'm sorry guys I'm flip-flopping on this
but I I don't know if I would put like
Fitness in it concretely but I do think
it like helps to make you more high
value because I do think other in order
to be high value other men have to
respect you yes like you could get a ton
of money win the lottery tomorrow but no
other men are gonna respect that but but
and I do think like men sort of size
each other up to see if they can like
fight and so that kind of lowers you a
bit yeah I mean it's a competitiveness
between men yeah it's not the number one
thing that you should focus on I mean as
a man who wants to be a high value man
but just the nature of man of being
competitive or having this like big Aura
even when uh like strong people walk in
a room they're like kind of uh oh who
are the people here yeah you know that's
the only thing but but I guess the
question is do you whatever our
definition is right what does he get
there quicker without a family it's not
a criteria because a family is very
important if the family will give him
the emotional stability to perform
better why not see I think like okay
I I think because my dad he didn't start
his like he he had a kid um with my mom
when he was in his early 20s and they
ended up giving that kid up for adoption
and then they started their family later
right so um I think my dad was in his
late 20s and I think it would have been
like I don't think he would have gotten
to where he was as quickly if he started
us earlier
ice and so that's why I understand what
he's saying with the vasectomy thing but
I don't I don't know if a vasectomy is
like a good idea you know
I don't agree with the vasectomy part of
uh what he says but from the family it
depends on each man I mean generally as
I said generally if you put your focus
on one thing you achieve it faster yes
yes for sure because you gather all your
energy just to get to the point where
you want to re arrive but there are uh
as you're human some people need that
emotional support maybe a man while he's
uh with a wife or do you think high
value men typically need emotional
support to get where they're going
um
I wouldn't say to get but just a
reference like a pillar a safety a sense
of home
because it's something that's uh that's
linked to their upper brain gain or
their childhood I mean we human are
different so all right let's let's watch
watch a little more I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to plan guys I I'm a positive
sometimes so I'm gonna try to let this
play Forever
did he feel stupid with like six or
seven or okay I mean
I'm just curious clarifying it out it's
just eight things I mean you could have
said put them together I guess the best
person to ask a question two is roll it
directly that's true so we'll do it next
week probably I'll tell you but this
list is concise because once again he's
just saying in general faster way to get
to that point yeah what is high value
man
I think he means what he means in this
context is getting being a guy that's
like desirable to women and being money
being attractive to women so that you'll
be uh I guess a marketable sexual party
but that doesn't make sense right like
avoid family creation and get a second
be attracted to men well no no
again like I said it before I'll say it
again because you're here
so he gave the instructions to [__]
proof it right because when you give
advice typically you have to you know
appeal to the lowest common denominator
so like there's guys out there right
that could have been being honest here
there's guys out there that you know
Mighty could have played basketball back
in the day maybe football whatever and
their career got smashed because they
got a girl pregnant and they couldn't
pursue what they want to do because they
had to be a dad early so what he's
saying is okay this is how you mitigate
risk so you could become a higher status
guy we're going to eliminate all the
things that could [__] you up now I want
to make this very clear for some of
y'all because some of you guys don't
understand I'm not saying I advocate for
vasectomies or whatever I don't have one
I've never gotten one but what I am
saying is that given the context of what
he's tweeting for this specific
situation
it makes sense because he's saying hey
these are the ways so that you don't
[__] yourself up to ensure that you're
going to be successful he's [__]
proofing it but that is a pretty
[__] advice because you're saying do
this so that you become more attractive
to women so what's even the point of
having a relationship with a woman if
you can't have kids with her then you're
just having an empty relationship just a
[__] her for your whole life and no he's
saying to become high value which means
you made the choice do you want to do
that or not so he's gave you the choice
to do that but once it becomes Myron
just said that it's to become high value
to become attractive to a woman yeah if
that's what you choose I feel like we're
two months away from tweets of like give
your bro like the key to your [__]
[__] Chastity cage to make sure that you
guys are [__] around without
permission whatever like I feel like
don't you guys tweet all the time about
how like oh like women are [__]
disgusting that are freezing their eggs
at like 20 and they're gonna find out I
know you've got like guys that go to
sperm clinics like here you go I'm never
gonna be able to impregnate my wife
because it's like a 30 reversal rate on
this [__] surgery but maybe in the
future
he has two points 90 reversal rate yeah
actually well
vasectomies yeah to Get It reversed and
be able to actually after like 10 years
it's like 30 to 50 yeah but your 20s or
ten years you're supposed to do you're
supposed to reverse it back within the
time yeah
you get 20 become a high value by 23 and
then get it reversed like I mean I'm
gonna say 23. you're being extremist
well he said your 20s that's 10 years
yeah but you could do it but when you're
28 29.
so nine years what is it 45 chance of
reversal bro you're not gonna have kids
anymore sterilizing half your audience
he had two points there he said what do
you think
Well I this is the worst advice that you
can give to anyone on Earth because you
you're not calculating the health risks
I mean you can just like state it and
say to people what to do because there
are some people who believe so like have
this uh full trust in that person and
who who will just do whatever he says so
this is very
um unhealthy but this I just think that
they said becoming a high value man is
for the purpose of attracting women I
don't think so I think that becoming
high value man is to prove uh you're
like a man proves himself among his
peers more than to attract women because
um even like a man in his 20s if he just
want to fake the aspect of a high value
man he can just like rent a car or wear
something attract women so so two things
I do think that the vasectomy wasn't
meant to be advice but the issue is
there's there's always going to be dumb
people watching you that will take it
that way and so when I was like
listening to him I heard it as like if
you want to make it foolproof right so
even somebody
that's
like basically I took it as his point
was to avoid starting a family until you
get to where you're going then start the
family
but but the issue is I just think when
you ward it like that like people will
take it the other way yes definitely I
mean it could have chosen another way to
broadcast his message in a clearer way
because yes if he just says don't get
yourself involved in like having kids or
something before getting to the your
desired outcome it makes sense because
having another responsibility will make
you a bit deviate from your route yeah I
think it's just like a vasectomy is the
only way that there's no chance yeah
like do you mean because a condom can
break you know like pull out you know
but
although what about abstinence what
happened to abstinence you know yes am I
wrong guys is abstinence not a not an
option it's abstinence not because
actually
you know if we're gonna make it
blessing am I wrong okay if you're gonna
make it the quickest way to become a
high value man right
could you say that abstinence would
actually be the quickest way I'm not
saying everyone should do that but if
we're gonna like stick to quickest
I want to speak about this for me yeah
because because then you spend no time
on women zero yeah
yeah look at I've added something okay
we can we can switch it sorry go ahead
oh my God I mean I like that point I can
even speak about this from like an
energetic perspective because when uh
you know the the sexual act is uh a man
just like you know a sports guy
sometimes they abstain because they they
know that it's like a valuable energy
that they could use to achieve like uh
their uh I mean when they're in that
sport so they abstain it's the same in
all areas of life it's a valuable energy
that if you keep for yourself you use it
to reach your uh desires uh faster
rather than just uh well besides the
fact of seducing women and yeah I'm just
thinking quickest because he used the
word quickest and I'm like you could
substitute vasectomy for abstinence I'm
not saying everyone should do that but
that's just how I think okay avoid what
family creation and three Sesame
twenties you can choose what you want to
do I'll play what you need to apply he
just saying you could do either or
I'm worried that Rolo's kids are going
to have any questions
he's giving that that advice those
things are to mitigate fuck-ups yeah so
that you get on your path to becoming
higher status that's the Medicaid [__]
ups it's not about this is gonna this is
this is so you can uh [__] have a
bunch of kids and have a family that's
not the advice advice is this is how you
mitigate Cubs in your 20s so that you
can become attractive now again like I
said before am I telling guys go out
there and get a vasectomy no no but he's
giving that these points because if you
follow those things it's gonna be very
difficult for you to [__] your life on
that list he's got two things okay about
your dick okay about avoid family
creation gonna protect me is there
anything on the list but like just avoid
women but holy Temptation hold on hold
on oh yeah okay me and look at me and
Destiny were on the same wavelength are
me and Destiny coming together now maybe
I'll maybe I'll uh cause men we want
women no matter what but whether we want
to I'm standing or be more it doesn't
matter however question for you guys on
the panel if you had a kid be honest
here would you be where you're at right
now destiny had a kid no no well oh you
did yeah
okay he's very successful it was a lot
of difficulty of course yeah but be
honest though you're wait Destiny's dad
yes this is what he said in his 20s
it is amazing I bet but at the same time
it did just call you back a little bit
of course yeah Chico for you would you
be in the same spot honestly if I had a
kid at what age are you talking about
earlier than like 20
I mean no you wouldn't be that's the
point here yeah who knows where I would
have been my life it would have been a
completely different life the point is
you might not even be here I'm just
trying to say he's saying mitigate risks
and say you know what avoid well I might
not be in the fresh and fit podcast
right now but I would have been
successful in different Realms and maybe
I would have taken a different path how
do you know why not just like use
protection yes okay that's a good point
and he said avoid what if I'm a
Christian which means he's a condom too
no it doesn't it says to me that was the
universe
number three number two says avoid what
crazy is it like this is like the list
of eight things to be successful pick
five it's that's the list listen build
your own lunchbox at Taco Bell like what
I thought you fell off that's the way to
be uh high value which means for example
mitigate risk that's all you're saying
hold on hold on hold on okay but here's
the part that I completed that's how I
heard it too like the way fresh is
that's how I heard it was it wasn't the
best way this is the quickest most
foolproof but I think I found a more
foolproof one abstinence
abstinence
what you should take it literally if
this is the Godfather of the red pill
right you guys all give this guy so much
credit I don't really know much about
like five books the hypocritical part
about it is that we make fun of girls
all the time for not controlling their
sexual urges and being hoes all the time
like she belongs to the streets all this
stuff you tell guys that they're losers
if they don't go to the gym they're
losers they play video games you're a
loser if you smoke weed you're a loser
if you watch sports you need to exercise
discipline but when it comes to girls oh
[__] get a vasectomy because you can't
control yourself because you're not
capable of exercising discipline why you
have to be disciplined in every single
aspect of life networking success all
this stuff actually I agree with him me
too I like what he says because this is
a very good example of self-control
because if you can control your sexual
urges I promise you'll make it in life
either as a man or a woman watching
sports playing video games you need to
be on your stuff but for women nut
inside girls with after getting a
transgender surgery that's the one thing
you can't be disciplined
can you stop [__] girls yeah
oh really yeah stop the cat hold it to
her right now don't [__] until you get
married well no no
see contradiction
yeah okay
so don't [__] until you get married I
swear to God you're saying no handshake
handshake
girl before yes has he had a vasectomy
no does he have any kids no there you go
Plan B so you would have had a kid which
means he's gonna at some point yeah hey
we're listening they still sell Plan B
no no but the point is that is the point
he's able to [__] girls not have a
protect me and still not have kids it's
possible number two say avoid form of
creation it could be Connor or Plan B be
the same to be extra another form of
contraception is what it is basically
but he didn't say that and that's that's
not a good form of contraception because
it's not supposed to be reversed that's
what the doctor tells you when you get a
vasectomy surgery it's like you cannot
expect this to be reversed that's not
that you shouldn't go into that thinking
that you're gonna reverse it and also
the better advice instead of saying
never [__] again maybe for the women
that I do but I think that's where he's
missing it's not advice ice he's not
saying do this
he's saying this is the quickest way but
you know when you have an audience you
have to take accountability of every
single thing you say because people
literally take every single word you say
and apply it and you I mean I can see
this on like in many people many
influential people even if he just like
saying what he thinks but people would
take it like in a little word by word
this is when it comes a bit dangerous do
you okay do you think it's Justin
Bieber's fault that his fans harass
Selena Gomez
because they dated for years they broke
up
um to an extent yes because
I stood there and said okay my fans I
love you just please don't approach this
no he does he has they still do it they
don't care
but he I mean he could have insisted
more because the fans you know I don't
think you can't control people that's
the correct like you don't know who's
what that's the thing like
people are crazy crazy people are gonna
do what crazy people are gonna do you
can't control people in a sense but
trust me when it comes to fans they
really care about their Idol yeah he
just switches or shows some like kind of
yeah this this agreement they will just
consider it a bit not fully not 100 but
to an extent yes yeah but because my
thing is Rollo kept saying it's not
advice so if he keeps saying this is not
advice this is just the quickest way to
do it what else is he supposed to do he
said this is not advice well he just
don't have to uh say things that are
related to health like to procedures
especially surgeries which is like a
life life generally but isn't that like
doesn't that become a problem because
then it's like we we have this internet
culture where everyone's like policing
what we can and can't talk about or he's
not allowed to talk about this or he's
not like aren't we supposed to have free
conversations knowing that in some cases
you're going to be right in some cases
you're going to be wrong of course but
this is where like the human my mind
should interfere as an adult or someone
who has ability to critical think and
find the right and wrong stuff but
um yeah this is yeah let's I think he's
going to call in so it'll be interesting
to see what prepare that she could be
the mother of your children maybe don't
spend time with hoes all the time
thinking I need a 50 girls so I
understand feminists and how [__]
they are maybe just don't [__] them
maybe women that you can see yourself
having a family with when you first hold
on that's right you won't be able to
detect that though you need experience
you need experience bro wait no no how
do you need experience what does that
mean how would you know what's good for
you if you never had it
do you think you need to [__] a girl to
tell if she's like family material no no
no no we're saying experience wise what
is experience no dating courting and
having that one-on-one experience okay
she's like she doesn't like this this is
where this doesn't work I can tell from
experience what works
I'm getting there okay no adding in sex
you can understand okay once this past
this point has passed I can see what she
really is because remember people put on
our front at the very beginning but we
have sex with somebody they more often
likely to show you who they really are
that is absolutely not true how many
stories do you hear of husbands who are
like my wife used to blow me every
single day and then as soon as we got
married all the sex stuff or we you know
we have dead bedrooms now we were super
active our first year but that is
absolutely not true sex can absolutely
change after you've gotten married and
you can tell yeah he's right I've talked
to divorce lawyers that say after two
kids the woman just stopped sleeping
with the husband
well is this like linked to the
psychological
State I mean state of the woman after
being married or just like because she
is with the same man and she there is no
like spark and the life is like that
um I think it's because women aren't
wives anymore and they don't look at sex
as a duty to their husband and they just
want to do whatever they want
think it's a real I mean it's concern to
the relationship sometimes when it's not
I mean there is no spark even the desire
goes yeah but I think even if there's no
spark your husband should still protect
you so even if there's no spark I think
that the women should still sleep with
her husband because it's your duty and
so that's why I say like it doesn't
matter if there's no spark like your job
is to sleep with your husband but at the
other I mean I I get your point but like
at the other hand why does the man give
this
um impression to the woman so he's not
desirable anymore this is what do you
mean this is a question mark like if a
woman loves the man like truly she'll
just like be surrendered to the man and
not have like those are there something
well I don't I think that Women Marry
men they don't love because they want
children
I think that happens all the time you
know women are most likely to cheat with
an ex so women get to like 30 32 35
they're looking around if I don't find
someone quick I'm not going to have
children so what does she do she grabs
grabs the first guy she can find gets
married that's why men don't a lot of
times don't want to date women over 30.
because there's too many exes that she
might have wanted more oh I mean I don't
I mean this is something everybody
cannot relate yeah but I think that's
what they're getting at is a lot of
times guys get tricked because they
think like a girl is a nice girl and
maybe she looks like a nice girl but
they don't know the signs of a girl
maybe that's not over her ex they don't
know the signs of a girl that's just
playing a part like your friends you
know before this um stream we were
talking about she's from Morocco and
when she was talking about her your
feminist friends you said maybe when
they're trying to get married they might
become conservative but if he's naive he
might not know what signs to look for
that she used to be a feminist and she's
just saying this for me to hear it
exactly yes I mean this is what I said
because this is from a personal
experience where if a woman is like has
been feminist and have like been free
and whatever once she wants to get
married she just like does yeah but the
man has to be smart because there are
some red flags that you could spot on
the first time you meet a woman I know I
I actually think that I know I know
women that hide it very well I know
women that have done crazy things and
hide it really well they're boyfriends
have no idea I I think like men if they
don't have experience they're gonna have
a really hard time differentiating
because our our ability to reproduce is
like especially those women like it's
incumbent upon them hiding hiding it
yes but that's what what he said I
understand sometimes when they say
practice for men I mean practice not for
like to be with in bed with a woman but
like to to know how to deal with a woman
red flags but I think I think that's the
point is like how do they know which was
a good woman and a bad woman without
experience and so it's like if they get
experience they don't want to knock at
the wrong girl up so even if they're
like because you know I I've I've done
this divorce documentary and so I talked
to women or men not women men that have
been absolutely wrecked in divorced now
I'm talking about one guy had his kid
taken by Child Protective Services his
kid's best friend died because there was
a group of mothers that were like
abusive towards the kids
oh wow so and his wife was one of them
and they wouldn't give him his chat like
I'm talking about like men that they
worked for 20 years to build themselves
up and I'm telling you I asked them
questions how old was she a lot of times
they're in their 20s
um where was she from the the one I'm
thinking of she was from Eastern Europe
which is very very sought after because
even if she's a good woman if she's in
the west we don't the culture is still
here even a good woman and what will
happen to them is good women
will be surrounded by a bad culture and
will be influenced because we're much
more easily like propagated than men we
were very much more influenced by
Propaganda so what they'll do is the
feminist groups will come in and tell
the women oh you've been
um like this is abuse this is coercive
control they'll like use these words and
convince the women that they're abused
even though they weren't like they can
like if if you said hey I want to spend
five thousand dollars on a credit card
to your husband you could come back and
say he financially abused me because he
said no and you can go to court and and
that's their point is like if you want
to become a high value man right
and like it is a big risk to get a girl
pregnant because she really can ruin
your life and I've spoken to these men
like
it's so sad and and they become like
it's so sad because they become like a
shell of a man like you can tell like
that before they were just someone else
but like imagine working for 20 years to
build something she takes all your money
you're on child support so you can't
even build wealth she takes your
children like you have nothing left yeah
and that's yeah and so I think their
point is like it is so risky to start a
family that you really need to be sure
so that's why they tell them and I'm not
saying it's right or it's wrong but I'm
saying like that's why they tell them to
go screw a bunch of girls so you can
tell that girl's faking that girl's
telling the truth because how else would
you know if you've never dealt with
women
yes I can see the their point as I said
um being around women will teach men to
spot red flags to spot uh how to know if
it's the right woman or not but then
there is another factor which is I like
to call it just luck because you never
know correct correct I agree with you I
mean you can be with this like one
gemstone of like the woman you've
dreamed of she's the nicest but once
you're with her for like I don't know
six months a year you start discovering
something you've never seen before and
without even the influence of like for
everyone no I I actually I agree with
you like it is luck like I don't think
there's a right girl like I think it's
just you you get lucky you pick the
right one because every every time a
guy's in a contract like the women are
paid to leave they're not and even even
I think even good women can make bad
decisions when we're angry yes because
we are emotional yeah yeah we are very
difficult yeah regardless of experience
you can tell who's a 304 who's like
family material without [__] them
first for you guys you can probably tell
everybody look in their Instagrams isn't
that what you guys are like
professionals at is picking out hoes
based on their Instagram pictures you're
telling me you have to [__] through like
30 women to find like how many
conservative men like we were in like
real conservative men who have strong
Families how many they're like yeah you
know I had to [__] 25 [__] when I was
in college the love of my life right now
they can take care of my kids that's a
wild statement but I think the
difference is back then women didn't
have social media and the culture wasn't
as degraded like and I think that's why
they tell them to do that
I mean social media now they can they
can expose a lot of things if men are
smart enough I promise like I've had a
lot of conversation with men like with
men who are with several women and they
tell me how they see like even Instagram
profiles what are the red flags and even
I mean the kind of comments or the
people the girl follows they just can't
spot it on the I mean for just the first
time you don't know any girls that hide
it hide it that like are are kind of
crazy but they hide it well no
quiz like even either the straight
forward that they just put everything in
pictures yeah or the very conservative
that alarm no I know a couple girls that
I went to like
I went to school what they were just
like you would never guess oh you would
that's fine but don't pretend you're
doing it and same with the girls
honestly from the documentary they
showed me like videos from when they
first got together the women seem sweet
and like it's like now they're like
ruining their life in divorce court and
I'm like how did they get from like this
one guy showed me pictures of him and
his wife and like they're happy as a
family they're doing all this fun stuff
and then I'm like how did you get from
that to know you're you're not letting
him see his children but I have a
question like yes I'm from man's side
like most of the time because I know
what women are capable of but sometimes
I think that men could hide
um could hide their uh the the little
thing that made everything that the
balance go backwards don't you think so
could you explain it more I mean
sometimes a behavior a pattern something
that's not visible to the outer world
that made that woman behave this way
um not to the extent to this to destroy
his life but just to switch the dynamic
of their relationship do men ever
contribute to breakups yeah I do I do
think they do
um but like my point is I'm looking at
they show me they bring like their
binder right they bring their document
of like the court case stuff like one
guy he had a text from the girl saying I
wish he would hit me because she was
trying to get him to like she had hit
him before he'd never hit her and she
was trying to get him to hit her and so
and so it's like how how did he
contribute to that not to say he was a
perfect husband but when the girl is
doing this crazy stuff and there was no
consequence like she didn't go to jail
she didn't she actually still got
primary custody yes yes and that's what
we don't like realize is a lot of times
like on the outside looking in it's like
well like what did he do but it's like
if he did anything he'll pay for it
exactly oh he'll pay for it the low is
just discriminating man and I can say
this like obviously the law is uh doing
bad things to men and given a lot of
advantages to women and this is not what
should be it's not it's not even it's
not even a woman's right anymore it's
not equality no it's it's equal it's
like it's um
it's destroying man yeah basically yeah
no and it does and I think that's why
sometimes like the red pill has like we
get a bad rap because we're like well
it's tough to push marriage when I I've
talked to the guys on the other side and
I'm thinking how would you avoid this
which is going to be one of my next
series I want to see if there's ways to
avoid this stuff like legally yeah
that's gonna be good because you know
marriage I I've spoken to men as well
they don't mind getting married if it's
like uh on church or like an Islamic way
but they don't just want to sign the
contracts and get a government involved
because everything they've built is
going to be taken off if they just done
the slightest mistake there's a super
chat I think marriage for men do you
think this is true or false I think
marriage for men should be around 35 to
40 in women 18 to 30 best chance for a
nuclear family Dynamic to survive I do
think that the more men get older the
more they're stable and able to maintain
a marriage better than younger men it's
just out of maturity maturity but for
women I I wouldn't say 18 18 is a kid
because a woman at 18 and at 25 she
could change her mindset completely from
this age I would say 23 ish maybe when
she started just knowing a bit of uh of
like her really personality about how to
behave I'd say from 23 it's a good age
and definitely a man from the 30s I
actually don't think it's bad for a girl
to get married at 18. I think it's okay
I mean I'm not gonna push it one way or
another I think 18 is okay 23 is okay
but I don't
um people used to get married at that
age all the time and the results were
better they stayed married longer if you
look at it if you look at like numbers
alone but if you you uh back in the days
they didn't have social media yeah
that's that's the problem nowadays yeah
now everyone wants the the Jets the you
know everyone is just like fighting for
like some crazy life and women just like
get uh sometimes they dream in a lot and
they could probably yeah no that's the
that's the dynamic um Rolo talks about
this in this in his book The issue
and and that's why we say there's no
good woman because again even a good
woman can still see social media and
think she's missing out on something
that's what he talks about is even a
girl like
um that made more of the
like she wants to get married young like
there's a lot of women that get the kids
early and then leave their husband at
like 30. yeah yeah that's that's
literally uh what I've seen from my life
I have family that they just got married
at 18 and divorced when they're 30. yeah
oh my God this man I don't like him this
is not me I deserve better I deserve
this caliber of men I'm this and this
and this yeah it's unfortunate in the
modern world I think actually the
longest marriages are from
I gotta double check guys please don't
roast me in the chat please don't I'm
sorry sometimes I I don't know off the
top of my head but I think it's like 25
to 30 is actually like the longest
marriages for women when you get married
but historically it's always been
younger
so it's and I think I think you're right
I think it's something to do with social
media but another Super Chat which we do
read super chat so you know good bad we
will read them pray not prenup prenup
not perfect but better than nothing if
she refuses to sign one dump her
insidiously looking out for looking out
for her interests over yours for this
[__] altruistic purpose of fighting a
good mom but Destiny can you admit that
when you meet somebody for the first
time right you're trying to see who they
really are the person and ultimately
you're gonna have sex right I mean you
don't have to but I mean you know having
sex is like the least important part of
seeing what kind of a person they are um
actually if you're compatible or not
it's very important but if you're
compatible but in terms of like would
this be a good mom
is it like what if she throws it back
doggy she'd probably take the kids like
out to the park every day like what does
that even mean like like she doesn't
swallow I don't think she'd feed my kid
if I didn't make it home what does that
mean okay like so she shows up to blow
me every night so I know she'll be on
time picking my kid up from school like
what is the correlation here the whole
package itself right is gonna include
sex I'm just saying the dating foxes
itself going through the whole motions
you can see who the person really is
that's all I'm seeing her he said he
wants to call in and tell us what he
actually meant
uh I guess I guess you know here's a
novel idea how about you tell me let me
call it to tell you what I actually
meant you know what let's do it bro
let's go ahead and bring uh roller
tomasion shots roll shout out to you can
you hear me okay what up man yeah we got
you okay okay
um so let me uh let me explain a few
things here I wasn't able to do this the
last time you guys were talking about
this but so about
oh my gosh gosh is it now two weeks ago
I I think it was a Tuesday of last week
you guys had Brandon Carter on is that
with with Derek moneyberg
so uh so Monday uh you guys were talking
to Brandon Carter one of the things that
Brandon was talking about was you gotta
love money you got to be on top of your
game and if you and I love Brandon
Carter by the way I think he should be a
uh he should be a stand-up comedian I
mean the guy is that funny he's a great
guy right but when you guys are on that
show and you're talking to him and he's
he's talking about how he doesn't go to
um well he doesn't go to Publix doesn't
go grocery shopping for himself he
doesn't go do his own laundry he doesn't
have a car uh I mean it's Brickle white
but he doesn't have like some basic
stuff because his philosophy in life is
this is that anything that takes him
away sorry I do read super chats
marriage is Honorable and all and the
bed undullified but whoremongers and
adulterers God will judge in his grind
anything that takes him away from that
from uh from anything that would
distract him or that would be
um financially or mathematically not a
pragmatic choice for him to make as far
as like if he's spending time going
grocery shopping or going and you know
getting food for himself or whatever
else I'm sure he's not getting a meal
prep and everything else but pretty much
everything in his life is is outsourced
because anything that he would be
spending that time himself to go do he
could be losing money doing that at that
time so when I was listening to this and
I was thinking about this myself because
I was actually at the same time I'm like
you know helping a friend move and all
this and I'm thinking about this I'm
going you know what if you want to be a
high value man if you want to get to
that Apex level as fast as you can
that's how is that not the the best way
to go about it okay so the point of
gentlemen Kane thank you for the Super
Chat
okay that whole tweet which was
basically a throwaway tweet that
everyone started like snowballing into
something else I've got Ben Shapiro
coming at me I got Matt Walsh coming at
me got Lauren Chen coming at me I got
all these people off of daily wire
because it was just easy low-hanging
fruit for these guys because they think
that that's what the [__] manosphere
is all about and it's not okay that was
not [__] advice every e-learn met my
wife when I was 17 and she was 15. I got
married three years later 18 years later
still happily married she likes the
husband more than hanging out with her
friends or anything else that is on
Twitter is not advice okay was that a
joke no it was not necessarily a joke
but it's like let's just say it's a
hypothetical okay
for just five seconds okay there's no
joke here because everything that's come
out of you guys's mouth has been nothing
but distraction in this direction
because it's easy clicks for you so
here's the whole thing when I'm talking
about get a vasectomy
when I'm when I'm talking about this
when I'm throwing this out there why
wouldn't you do that would you not have
been more successful snico had you not
had to go through certain things if you
had a kid right yeah you would be you'd
be playing the game with a handicap
you'd be playing the game with your
[__] uh hands tied behind your back
okay right now there are guys right now
who you who I have a lot of respect for
and I'm sure you have a lot of respect
for as well
who are who all have kids but you know
what they try to do try to keep it under
wraps nobody knows about the [__]
kids okay so here's okay first off this
is not advice everything that is on my
show or is on Twitter is not
automatically advice but here's the
thing I you know what you're gonna say
because here's the deal when I was when
I was on whatever podcast I was telling
this I was saying exactly the same thing
here is that everything that comes out
of somebody's mouth on Instagram or on
Twitter or on a YouTube there's no way
you can't go on there without somebody
going this is what these guys are saying
to do because if you have this set
automatically that if it comes out of
your mouth it's automatically advice it
can't just be data it can't just be
statistics it can't be nothing can be
just delivered
here's some data for you to look at okay
nothing can be nothing can be set
nothing can be given to you without
somebody going well the reason why
you're telling me this is because you're
telling me that this is the best way to
live my life okay so when I'm watching
Brandon Carter and watching all this
going on I'm looking at like guys that I
know and guys that you know as well and
when these are the guys who are like
saying you know be on your game do this
do that they're the ones that are giving
this advice all I'm doing is saying hey
look maybe you should not focus on
family maybe you should not get married
I mean that's I don't know why that's
big advice I'm not saying it's I'm not
saying it's advice what I'm saying is
over the [__] top that everybody
wants to take it out of out of context
which is exactly what you guys have been
doing so what is it can you tell me what
that tweet was if it wasn't advice it's
not advice what it is is it's it's okay
it's saying that this is the most
extreme way to do things okay here's the
uh here's the um the quickest path to if
I told you this look if I said the
quickest way for you to make a million
dollars that sounds like advice it's a
goal is to go steal it from the bank
yeah so this is what they're like
talking past each other because he's
saying this isn't advice this is what I
think is the quickest way to do it I'm
not saying you should do it but sneako's
trying to like pin him to the fire and
saying okay if that's not your advice
what is your advice and he won't answer
the question yeah because he understood
the um the weight of his words so now he
doesn't want to say something and be
reversed to the other side what do you
mean so he doesn't want to say something
and then they will take it against him
you know he's like afraid to just say
it's like like yeah to say what what's
his on his mind he goes to steal it does
that mean I'm telling you to go steal it
if I tell you to go [__] jump off a
cliff are you gonna go jump off a cliff
by the way
is I'm also responding to Dr Richard
Reeves in this as well okay there's a
lot of context about it sure but all the
rest of the list you're equating
vasectomy to lifting game play to your
strength resisting up on easing your
focus the rest of it sounds like general
advice let's say so so let me let me ask
you so is it the mastectomy part that's
throwing you off really genuine good
advice right the rest of us so is it
they said sneako snico and Destiny
mostly Destiny made snide remarks I'll
stream and Rollo triggered from the
start not a good look either side yeah
you see Dustin he does do that like he's
done that to me before
um where it's like you'll kind of like
the glasses thing you were saying like
that's kind of attacking him personally
it's not attacking the argument however
like it is your job and in a in a debate
you have to stay composed exactly you
can't you can't get mad about you know
about you the other person you're
debating like completely and utterly
like agree like there have been times
where I've been so pissed I have been so
pissed about something but I just you
know yeah because you cannot take it
personal I mean there we are discussing
ideas at the end so yeah yeah
but yeah I think that's where they're
having the disconnect though is because
Rolo's trying to say
um foreign
it's actually hard because I don't like
ideologically think that like a
vasectomy is the best way to do things
you know what I mean like I don't
because you know
um I'm conservative like I don't know
but but I understand like what Rolo is
trying like what he's saying is he's
saying this is not advice but he could
have just said it in a very easy word
which is discipline or abstinence or I
know I was like what if you said
abstinence would the internet be that
that man no I don't because people just
get mad when someone gives Health advice
yeah yeah because I'm thinking
if they waited because again the the
frame is the quickest way to become a
high value man because I'm thinking if I
do the Virgin at 35 good luck with women
you know what I mean good luck suffer he
would suffer yeah but but that's not the
question he says the quickest way to
become a high value man like I I think
abstinence would kind of fit
do you agree with pretty much everything
else except for the vasectomy part the
first three is weird because then I
don't even know what the red pill idea
of a high value man is is it just being
rich like what's the point of having all
this money yeah and that's the that's
where this whole debate has gone awry is
because everyone in the red pill is
different everyone I think everyone you
talk to is gonna have a different
definition of a high value man and it's
hard because whenever we list the things
like a high value man is I can always
think of someone that doesn't quite fit
it but still I would argue is I mean the
is this is it depends truly I wanna I
wanna pull up so the dark hold on it's
on my phone there's there is someone
Kevin Samuels is the only one
um I think that high value match would
have a lot of skill sets not only money
not only personality I mean it's it's a
skill set
uh okay let me Okay Kevin
uh let me find it all right high value
man 10K per month and you have to have
had it for three to five years
why uh because some people get get lucky
and get a really high paying job they
get fired they don't really have the
skills for it you know um so like even
online like some people blow up they're
really rich but three to five years you
can kind of see if it's here to stay
yeah uh which do you agree with that yes
or no yes I do okay because the ability
to sustain it means that you're smart
and you can control
um your thing uh the way your wealth
better okay other men must accept you as
high value
yes competitive yes amongst men yeah I
agree um you have to have a network of
high value men again yes
you have to have a LinkedIn visibility
level
not really
uh not all jobs yeah
you too because my dad I think is four
out of five he doesn't have LinkedIn but
I'm like he had a company of like three
to three hundred people well do you know
what I mean like he sold it I don't know
I'm a little partial to my father you
all know okay utility useful to others
in the group
um partially I wouldn't say a hundred
percent because if you have the
recognition of your peers you will you
are useful somehow why would they uh
give you that yes if you don't benefit
them yeah because it's kind of like are
you a high value man if you just stay by
yourself in the woods no of course no
um okay which all right the Christopher
Scott the problem is that sneak let his
girl do things with another man and
Destiny has a weird relationship where
he lets his wife sleep with other people
why do you listen to them why are you
arguing with the Godfather Madness but
the thing is like we're talking about
ideas so we're trying to say is what is
what is what they're saying true or is
it not true we're not like you know
um and people like if it's Destiny
having an open marriage is that relevant
to is this true or is it not true and
like that that's kind of what people do
when they don't have an argument it's
like they'll attack they'll they'll
bring oh snico did this or destiny has
an open marriage where it's like okay
let's go back is what is this is the
quickest way to do it yes or no exactly
I see your point you don't have to judge
people for their lives they're just
discussing ideas and we're discussing
whether high value men is is it the
quickest way to get to be high volume no
all right let's let's see I want to see
in the chat guys did we list anything
all right all right someone says history
has outlined what a high value man is
and it doesn't include having lots of
money some have had lots of money some
have not Kevin Samuel's definition is
narrow-minded uh Pearl that dress is too
short is it
guys I'm kind of tall I'm sorry I'm
sorry all right
um freaking
all right a high value man has been
established for years there's no qua
Quick Way money is the main qualifier
and I think this is where it gets so
hard in these conversations because
everyone is a different definition but
money doesn't make it's not the only
component that makes a man a high value
men I mean you can there are people who
are rich but
for example they are by themselves or
they have inherited that money I mean it
doesn't mean they're high value even if
they're like billionaires but they've
never worked for it or shown any social
skill or any in form of intelligence or
like belonging to a group yeah well I
think there's some people that get money
quick yeah and they're gonna lose it
eventually there ain't no way but but I
do think that's why they have like the
three to five years I think that was a
good addition because you know we see
these overnight like artists and stuff
that just but where is the for example
family oriented emotionally available
does does I mean it's not considered do
you think um do you think Trump's a high
value man
well like him or dislike him do you
think he's high value yes I do okay do
you think he's emotionally available
I don't think that's in the equation
I think like if anything high value men
are less emotionally available like they
don't really use their emotions
I don't think they have every man has a
little bit of a weakness some in some
kind shown or yeah but if we like take a
list of like 50 high value men and 50
non-high value men I think the high
value men would be less emotional in
general because I think men that make
more less emotional decisions do better
yeah so yeah so I'm gonna say no
no to the emotion what was the other one
you said I'm gonna we can decide
together if we keep it I said
emotionally available and family
oriented
yeah
um
I don't think family oriented
because again like I think I would say
Trump's a high value man but he's been
married three times all his kids like
he's like how many different baby like
you could argue like some conservatives
would say he's not high value because of
that oh no but I'll just just because of
this but I still he got married and he
has kids so wow women come up with um
the basic ideals of a high value man in
the 80s magazine oh really is that true
Doug
money was a big part of it men had to
embrace the concept and adapt adapt it
was the shift in the dating Market do
you have any proof of this dog you could
send me
um okay we're gonna keep going I'm
having a family why be that rich the guy
who's always grinding whoa Brandon
Carter doesn't have to do his laundry
sick what else are you gonna do with
your life right right maybe this is
actually meant so that you'll get it
you'll have a freaking Epiphany about
how there's how the all the [__] that
you have to sacrifice to get to that in
the first place what are you willing to
sacrifice are you willing to are you
willing to live the kind of life let's
say like a Brandon Carter is where
you're going to Outsource your entire
life or are you going to actually have
kids is that something that's a priority
for you because I will tell you right
now that if you do if you follow this
kind if you would have actually follow
this list right here that is the fastest
way for you to get to a point where you
are more high value right so here's the
thing so when I say that people go well
that's not what a high value man is a
high value man is what I Define it as
which is he's got to have he's got to
have a good loving you know devoted wife
she's got to have uh he's got to have
three or four kids or ten kids depending
on whatever culture you're talking about
all this stuff that makes up whatever
that person who happens to have that is
then that suddenly oh that's true
because he says he's no because Rolo
says
people say that like I I didn't hear
this the before
P like whoever is speaking whatever they
have they want to equate to high value
men like up to their standards personal
standards okay so it's kind of like if I
said hey what you should look for in a
high value woman is a tall Ginger right
is a tall redhead that plays Sports okay
that's a high value woman that's what
they're doing with oh that's good like
they they are projects yeah qualities
their qualities onto the like what they
want to do
this is a very very intriguing high
value man interracial relationship sex
dating marriage high value men applies
financially sexually socially
um
and someone says the the man the other
men want to be and the other women want
to bang yeah yes this is a good
definition
I'm so sorry guys I I'm all over the
place in this reaction uh William
recommes thank you for becoming a member
you don't have to embody what you
advocate for to be valid that is a
fallacy does your cancer doctor need to
have cancer
I'd say it they project like their ideal
selves not even what they are yeah yeah
I mean what they it's like that's what I
was thinking too it's like their value
system no but it's interesting though
because we're going to keep notion of
what a high value man is so what I'm
saying I'm saying this is the best way
to become a high value man I'm not
saying this is the only way to become a
high value man I'm just saying that this
is the fastest way to go and do
something like that I've been talking a
lot for five minutes what is your
definition of a high value man it
doesn't matter that's not what I was
talking about in this matter what you're
talking about that's what the front of
the first part of the Tweet is how to
become a high value mix fastest way to
become a high value man is to recognize
to recognize the fact yeah they made a
point they did he they made a point
there because if you're gonna tweet it
you have to have the definition exactly
and be brave enough to say in front like
to say what your definition is
and I know what Rolo's gonna say he's
gonna say but at whatever definition you
say they're going to argue with and I
think that's true
but at least you stand for your correct
correct because like it almost makes the
argument easier if we say okay this is
what the definition we're gonna say it
is if you disagree that's fine but this
is the definition we're working with
yeah definitely it would be a great
starting point for this debate
yeah high value although but this is the
problem I had I did a stream
um with him
I had to pull it there was some subjects
talked about that we had agreed we would
not speak on due to YouTube guidelines
okay yeah yeah you got to be careful on
this okay yeah but so what we did was we
um and and that was the problem was we
had people that were more Christian on
it and so they said well my definition
of a high value man is this and so then
we couldn't even have the definition the
question of is this the fastest way to
get there because everyone's arguing
about because I said okay guys this is
the definition like that's what I did I
said this is Kevin Samuels he's the only
one who's laid it out here like the five
I read to you and then the Christian
people were like no no my definition is
moral no my definition has kids and so
it's like it's so frustrating as a host
because nobody can agree to the premise
of the debate yes I mean you have to for
example the starting point is to set
yeah
and that's what we should have did we
should have said I don't care what what
you guys think like this is what we're
gonna argue it is we can do another
debate with your definition and argue is
this the quickest way to get there
um okay high value man is a guy that can
get stuff done 100K is not a lot of
money and it's hard to believe that a
man can get it done in struggles with
money but then I think of like there's
people that are artists or like do you
know what I mean in fields that make
like no money but sometimes there's
stuff outlasts their lifetime exactly
but then are we talking about the
exception instead of the rule I'm
thinking but you know sometimes not even
I I wouldn't agree if to say like a
standard for like an income to say for
money if a money is a high value man
sometimes you just spot the ability in a
man to create wealth or like to have the
ideas and if you demonstrate this for
like even 50k that grows to 100K that
could be so if what if he stays at 50k
and never gets to 100K can he be a high
value man
if he has the other components I would
say yes okay
um I I became incredibly incredible
incredibly rich and it made my Social
Circle smaller due to Envy it's a real
challenge to see this
um
gifted tpg pjx one gifted membership
yeah yeah
um high value men and women is simple
personal definition personal
interpretation not one single person has
on the planet has the same definition
End of Line that's what makes this combo
so hard so hard
um
actually God that you've got sacrifices
to make okay telling like stories from
Vietnam like just say what is a high
value man it's the first part of the
Tweet what does that mean you tell me
what a high value man is because here's
the thing is it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I'm going to say is
a high value man because it's your Tweet
it doesn't matter what I say is a high
value man because everybody takes this
the point of the [__] tweet is that
everybody is going to take this and then
insert their own definition of what a
high value man is
yeah but you have to answer the question
like if you're gonna tweet it we we need
an answer from you like what did you
mean so we can debate it that that's
where they're they're getting him
exactly I mean for me I see that he
doesn't even know that's what my
presumptions are well kids when you're
16.
then your Tweet doesn't work does it
what if your definition of a high value
man is being uh getting into a trade and
having five kids by the time you're 22.
being an Esports professional you're
absolutely making my point for me right
here okay this is what I'm saying my
point is you gave a list of eight things
do these eight things to become a high
value man do one through eight to be
come a and you're not defining what a is
the fastest way to becoming a high value
man is these toys because you know what
I was thinking I'm like some people
would say a guy that's a high value man
has like a million kids
do you wanna you know what I mean like
some people will say it's like a genetic
thing where they have to have as many
kids as possible yeah I mean but that's
the thing it's it's very personal again
but I think that he should have answered
the question so they can even judge him
yeah no I agree they're debating better
than him in my opinion what is that so
here's the thing so if we're talking
about family creation okay let's go one
by one you want to go one by one okay
before one by one what is a high value
man we can't have an argument if I don't
even know what you're definitely is but
the very fact that you're even asking
this in the first place is the actual
point of the [__] tweet okay so if
you got if you're going to be a high
value man with a [__] hands tied
behind your back then what is that what
does that mean to you that's the point
this whole discussion is the point of
the [__] tweet
was you've got some conception of high
value man here are eight points you
think you need to do to get to it and
now you're getting blown the [__] up on
the vasectomy thing which you probably
realize is [__] [__] but you're
too old and summer to walk back that's
the point of discoveries and walk back
from it because the point of it was to
get douche nozzles like yourself to have
this conversation in the first place how
old are you bro
douche nozzles yes you guys are idiots
why don't you guys come in here from
Twitter like how you guys are legitimate
in all this I don't know because
everything up here come out of you guys
mouth is just confident ignorance
okay I'm not asking you like in terms of
the debate you call yourself The
Godfather or the red pill you would tell
myself The Godfather of their manosphere
okay other people have called me that
okay great do you understand okay so
how's that another grandfather of the
minute which one is whatever it is the
old guy of the manosphere what is your
definition of high value mad this is the
number one talked about topic on all of
these shows and so I want to get a clear
definition from you what is it
do you tell again it depends on the
person it depends on the culture it
depends on the so here's the thing let
me let me tell you maybe I can explain
this to you sneako because at least you
got it you got your ears open here the
thing is is that when we're talking
about what's the top G what's a high
value guy you probably haven't heard
this because you don't read my stuff and
you don't watch my [__] but I've also
said this is like it the red pill has to
be for everybody or has to or it's for
nobody so if we're looking at a guy
who's draped across a Lamborghini and
he's got hot chicks with them and we say
that's what I'm aspiring to but I'll
never make that because I live in a
fishing Village on the coast of Chile
right that means I can never be I can
never match that that high Apex of a
high value the guy in the car but the
guy who who happens to live in those
Villages or happens to be in a different
culture or in a different country or
whatever else he can still benefit from
that because however he's defining
himself as a high value man in his
fishing Village maybe that's what he
that's what he is he has nothing to do
with Chile in the village in the car
the thing is you guys want you want you
guys want me to say okay a high value
man makes a hundred thousand dollars a
year he's [__] 50 Chicks he's like
that's the that's the thing not what I
want you to say I disagree with that I'm
asking you because I come on just all
disagree with that what I'm saying is
the point of the Tweet is so you will
ask that question I passed the Tweet I'm
past that look I'm asking if somebody
who's really interested in the red pill
I listen to a lot of this content I want
to know what your definition is because
if you have a definition that's
completely off of what I think it is
then I guess I'm not red pill well
here's what here's okay so here's what I
think a guys ought to do would you like
me to give you some prescriptions is
that what we're trying for here no I
want to know your opinion of a high
value man what is it you know I thought
I think a high value man is whatever is
contextually makes that guy a high value
guy in whatever culture that he happens
to be in if that's money that's money
right all right I'm gonna break down
what he said I think that a high value
man
wait wait let me listen to it again I
want to listen really closely it's ought
to do would you like me to give you some
prescriptions is that what we're trying
for here no I want to know your opinion
of a high value man what is it you know
I thought I think a high value man is
whatever is contextually makes that guy
a high value guy in whatever culture
that he happens to be in okay a high
value man is what whatever makes him a
high volume one in his culture whatever
makes him a high value man in his
culture okay so he's saying it depends
on a high value man depends on the
culture money that's money right now
that's what we tend to focus on right
now okay okay I think that's true right
now it's money but we haven't always had
money so before it was resources maybe
yeah or power or anything yeah okay I
think that's true if it's it's so but if
I'm gonna say that man is a guy that has
the things that makes him a high value
man
make you a high value man okay what is
that yeah
we just kind of because here's the thing
when I read the tweet I interpreted it
right a higher like he's listing things
that if you follow these things right
and you actually follow them you're
probably not going to become a right and
to be a high value guy I would say it's
a couple combination of things obviously
having your money on point having social
proof and Status having respect from
your peers having a network of other
high value men right which I agree with
Kevin Samuels on that being fit to a
degree if you have all these things in
place you'll be considered a high value
Man by most people in most societies
right if you have these things in place
now with that said to get there right
you obviously have to focus and get your
[__] together and make sure that you
focus on getting there what he's saying
is all these the the list of things that
he mentioned if you follow them it's
going to mitigate your risk of becoming
a [__] up and not getting to that point
as quickly as possible and I think
that's so important is that this tweet
kind of gets taken out of context he's
saying the quickest way to become a high
value man uh avoid and do these things
because you're limiting distractions and
he's using Brandon Carter as an example
where he's a monogamous relationship
with a girl he outsourced a lot of his
things why so he's able to focus on
making more money he's getting rid of
obstacles and I think that tweet
demonstrates that we're getting rid of
obstacles so you can become a Highwayman
in the quickest spot what possible way
yeah I think Byron gave a really good
answer here I think his explanation like
actually makes sense you agree yeah and
he's like because he's saying this is
what it is this is the quickest way to
get there without because in all other
ways you have variables so even if you
yeah because I guess if even if you
choose the abstinence route like maybe
you you know you go out and you you know
they read a a nice pretty girl and and
then they end up that's why I think
there is no like rule there's just
minimize the distraction and focus on
yourself and direct your energy towards
your goals I mean The Savvy The Savvy
ninja says if we take time to look
throughout history we would find common
qualities of men people viewed as high
value as a baseline of high value men
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do like a stream
on this like with a more definite a
definitive answer I'm sorry guys maybe I
should have one but every time I think
of a definition I keep thinking of and I
think it's because I'm a woman you know
where we think of exceptions but
okay we're just gonna keep going yeah I
know the most controversial one is the
second one man like ask just men what
are the definition how do you uh I said
I'm gonna make that a community post
well what all right guys what
as a man how would you what is your
definition
of a high value man
comment below
that's going to be interesting
yep all right guys I've put out a poll
no there's other ways to get the same I
guess effect from vasectomy let's say
you use a condom let's say you pull out
whatever it may be he's saying okay if
you get the vasectomy then we know for a
fact you're not gonna have children yeah
it's really no different than having a
condom or pulling out or whatever may be
the point is to not get a girl pregnant
how you want to get there is up to you
whether it's through a vasectomy using
condoms whatever but he's making it
[__] proof hey it's vasectomy because
I know even if you are the dumbest guy
ever you can't [__] this up I don't
think a [__] guy could be a high
value guy no when I say [__] I mean as
in stupid but what I'm saying is that
the point I'm trying to make is this
list is the foolproof way if everything
is followed for you get your status up
as quickly as possible in your 20s
that's not that's not what the list is
though because what you just said was
advice and he said it's clearly not
advice so you have you're interpreting
it he said he's joking
just for jokes but I'm telling you I
started out telling you guys how I
interpreted that yeah right
problem is he's using tradcon to Define
high value however Einstein is
considered a high value but him having
children is a part of it
but him having children is a part of it
the Divine son oh so he did have kids
but that seemed like the same thing
Jayla Rosa thank you for the super
Tasha's funny he asked a question
earlier sir you asked him a question
what is high value you answered it is
whatever you determined out to be
because no that's [__] none of you
guys believe that God comes on this show
he weighs 350 pounds and he says I'm
Diamond one in League of Legends that's
what I want to do with my life would you
go well that's what you really want your
high value you wouldn't say that no but
once again it starts in the mind you're
gonna say for example oh that's not true
I agree that's not true but ultimately
you as a man to say what's that about
here for you no you don't yes you do
value is probably something that's
determined by Society high value value
means that you have a Worth to other
people you're just talking about being
comfortable don't have a nice
self-esteem I agree but the tweet and
don't say you agree man I just said the
total opposite I agree I don't think you
need kids to be high value I think that
life is more fulfilling with kids I I
think that like life I agree with smiko
where he says like life isn't fulfilling
if you don't have children and I I do
think like that's the most important
thing
for women I don't think even for a man
you know Legacy yeah he has built all of
this he wants someone to benefit from it
right but I'm just thinking like I swear
oh please don't roast me in the chat I
know there are influential like super
influential men in history that didn't
have children
and and that like that I don't think you
could say they're not high value because
they influence history and like let me
just I'm gonna I'm gonna think of an
example but I don't want to say it
because I'm afraid I'm wrong okay wait
I'm gonna look it up before I say it did
he have kids
um okay like George Washington do you
know who that is yeah of course yeah so
he had no children okay so I don't think
you could say he's not a high value man
just because he didn't have kids
yes definitely because because I think
like men's value is more like what they
create that's more of their legacy where
Women's value is more of their children
but like I'm not saying that kids are
not important yeah but I understand
um the aspect for example a high value
man would uh generally would want to
leave his legacy to be uh in the hand of
another person which is uh technically
his son to take care of it but it
doesn't Define him his value okay so the
question is can you be high value with
no children yes of course yeah okay so
we don't so in the definition it
shouldn't have what do you think
blessing high value men no kids it was
George Washington still a high value man
definitely yeah yeah so kids can't be in
the definition nope no okay
for example people determine you at high
value however the Tweet saying high
value could mean in your in your sense
whatever that means to you no it doesn't
what that's what he's saying no he's not
he he doesn't know because he doesn't
okay wait there's someone saying you
need to spread that value around the
world most high value men didn't focus
on becoming high value they tripled down
on their purpose and becoming the best
and their purpose made them high value
high value is a product of purpose like
a definition because he knows if he says
anything he's gonna get you sound like
the girls who believe they're a 10
because they describe themselves of a 10
in the mirror right and this is the
problem because he won't lock down a
definition then he like then now he's
saying well okay because what are you
saying isn't true you can't just say
anything's a high value man but yeah
I'm sorry I feel like a flip-flopper
this debate I'm sorry Chad I'm sorry you
know I'm sorry because they both have
really good points I think this is like
actually such I look at content as art
yeah this is a really weird way to like
look at things okay but I love like
conversations that like push the
conversation forward and make people
think and I almost think like when you
create a conversation like that it's
almost like a work of art exactly and
and I and I think this like uh it's
weird because it's not about the look
but I think this conversation is almost
a work of art because people are gonna
think I'm so weird for thinking this but
because it like pushes the conversation
forward sorry go ahead yeah I mean did
you see how many people are arguing and
debating and yes never says the same
thing over and over that's a piece of
art so I get your point
and he's like I'm high value because I'm
a manager at my McDonald's you probably
wouldn't agree is that when he says high
value you're going to determine that as
a man what does that mean for you
success is a part of it yes but there's
this could be one of the form or having
a business it doesn't matter he's saying
to get to that point you need Focus
ultimately that's that's what he's
saying just just be focused that's a I
mean we make fun of the girls all the
time for saying that they're 10 out of
tens all the time because they say it in
their head I believe I'm a 10 out of 10.
no that's that's ridiculous because
Society determines how attractive you
are Society determines how valuable you
are you can't apply that a lot you can't
make fun of the girl the ugly fat whale
who thinks she's a 10 girl boss Queen
and then also say a high value man to
believe it in his head
well I gave you guys a 10 when I from
you have a good definition
because here's the thing for me I will
Define it because that will allow you
guys to see where I'm coming from when
I'm interpreting that we know where
you're coming from but we have the Tweet
out there he doesn't know where he's
coming yeah he should just Define it
that's right so we're trying to figure
out you know what exactly he means but I
think again the tweet I think that's the
important part of the Tweet is that it
allows people to interpret how they want
and which is why we're talking about it
right now the Tweet yeah
I'm giving advice to people I don't want
them to interpret it how they want
otherwise what the [__] is the point of
my message not giving advice to people
that's the whole point of this
it's impossible to put anything out
there without it about people
interpreting it as follow these steps
here's your 12 rules for life and you're
going to live up please bring a high
value man that's literally what your
Tweet was do these things what is the
wording of the Tweet go back to the
Tweet itself so here's and so in in that
wording as we what am I what's the last
part of that what's the last one resist
easing up on your focus whatever's like
would you want me to insert what you
ought to be doing you ought to be coding
is that what I should say you ought to
be uh becoming a professional athlete I
don't know what your [__] strengths
are you can sympathize here work hard
again if I'm so here's the thing if I
say here's if I say you know what you
ought to be an NBA player and it doesn't
matter if that you're five nine [__]
stand your focused and you're gonna be
the best NBA player you can possibly be
terrible advice now be an absolutely
terrible advice because this is a advice
that's why okay this is a list that is
meant to get so you get an idea of what
the [__] it is that you're going to do
so that you can become that high value
man protect yourself don't get married
avoid family creation that second again
this is over the top [__] anybody who
knows anything about my material when I
throw this out there they know this is
over the top [__] what else needs a
[__] fire for like for like douche
nozzles
I don't want to be a douche nozzle but
what else yeah besides number three what
else here is over the top besides
vasectomy a lifkin consistently okay
well what like
vanity right there's no way you agree
with that saying Listen Hold On Foreign
guys see here's the thing but you're
missing like you're are you not hearing
anything he's saying like do you need to
blindly agree with him because nothing
he's saying is making any sense bro it's
not making any sense to you because you
don't understand the concept of the
Tweet that's why you can't even
thoroughly understand what okay Glenn
holds up here did you understand what I
was saying about Brandon Carter yeah he
doesn't do his laundry no but he's taken
everything to this extreme level to a
lot of guys
okay would you agree with me that
Brandon Carter is a high value guy sure
okay you know who wouldn't Ben Shapiro
you know who wouldn't a lot of other
people because they think that they're
living out their own high value ideal do
you understand that
context
like the 350 pound Esports player he's
living on his ideal of a high value man
yeah whether or not that's working for
him is he he's he's talking about the
kids thing because the Trad cons will
all say you have to have kids and good
morals to be high value
that's what they'll say so he's saying
like because that's their definition
they put it on other people that's what
he's saying and snico is saying just
give us an answer what do you think and
Rolo refuses to answer I mean I don't
like the way he speaks because he's like
uh attacking in a way but rather than
just uh explaining himself and he's very
broad no yeah well he gets he's getting
I don't know you just got to stay here
tweet when I say okay when I'm talking
about Brandon Carter you say you
understand that he's taking it to like
this extreme level
what do you think Brandon Carter's
definition of a high value man is
probably the same as mine which is
determined by Society if you have
respect from your community then you are
a high value person if people respect
you
you don't get it Rollo couldn't win with
those two an answer he gave them would
have been used against him as a
non-answer yeah that's what I said
earlier that's the problem when you give
a definition of a high value man they
just like turn it oh my God that's
totally what happened on the stream the
other day
um people always say money is a massive
factor in high value man but I argue
that a man of average means whose impact
who impacts the lives are hundreds of
thousands of people is also high value
you see that
this is where we get into it's like a
never-ending it's a never-ending Circle
um what do I think though I'll tell you
guys what I think people
a man of average means whose impacts the
lives of hundreds
the life in what way I mean we have to
be specific
what about Gandhi right because it
couldn't Gandhi be an example is he a
high value man with their standards no
with their standards no he's an
influential but but I think that Gandhi
would
I think he would be because he he has so
much influence but it's like a guru more
no
no actually you know I'm
or I'm because there has to have been
influential people throughout history
that didn't have money they're half to
have been go ahead I wouldn't say it's
about money it's about influence the
fact that we're still talking about
Gandhi makes him high value
yeah Dandy Mandela or high value Jesus
high value yeah we still talk about them
today
and they have followers or their ideas
yeah no I think you're right
can an evil man be high value I think
yes yes I think an evil man can be I
don't think it's a morality thing it's
got to be like money and influence well
my money isn't a necessity so maybe it's
more influence yeah
yeah you disagree I agree
no no no I'll say influence is more more
of a catalyst to becoming a high value
man because
yeah an evil man can be so what what
about people that have a lot of money
but they're behind the scenes and nobody
knows who they are let's do a high value
because as much as they are behind the
scenes there are people that are
all the kids subject to them in terms of
like if a Workforce they have people
that follow them their ideologies and
stuff like that so if you have an idea
and you have a bit of followers that
kind of makes you high value
okay like let's say like an enemy of
state in America is still alive is it Mr
is Mr Beast a high value man yeah
okay
what about so because I would think like
it can't be all influencers right maybe
not Mr Beast
um but I just I think of like some of
the tick tock influencers that
okay what we call influences nowadays is
like like someone who just has a
following but in terms of social
following but there's like influences
that have ideas that have right right
like Kevin Samuels was a high value man
Andrew Tate was a high value man but
some random tick tocker dancing not a
high value man you can have like 10
million followers but are we going to be
talking about you in in 10 years in 10
years and if Mr Beast died Tomorrow
People we we would hear about him yeah
he broke and he he changed YouTube yeah
okay
and having people like you and and
depending on no you don't agree with
them because the daily wire Ben Shapiro
is definitely a high value man okay but
okay so okay so let's just say for sick
he does he sets up here is a high value
man Advantage fair is a high value man I
gotta
I gotta disagree with that yeah let's
take do you know Ben Shapiro is nope oh
Ben Shapiro's like um conservative maybe
gosh I show her Ben Shapiro after this
stream maybe I'll show you one do I
think he is I don't think he's a high
value
he owns his own business is like one of
the most successful all media Platforms
in the world he's married he's [__]
young sweetheart right right you know
who else is not a high value guy Elon
Musk let's see uh who else uh Jeff Bezos
all you got to do is just well all you
have to do is look at the decisions they
made in their personal lives okay how
are we going to Define that if I'm going
to Define that yeah you haven't you're
the only one who happened to find it
yeah I'm not the one defining it for
[__] Jeff Bezos I'm not the one
defining it for [__] uh what's his
face whale can think she's a 10 as long
as that's how she defines Beauty to
herself you guys justify well well fine
you guys well hold on wait Niko You just
defined Brandon Carter as a high value
guy right yeah
okay
definition of high value guy but I will
tell you right now that if that would
not fit the same definition that say Ben
Shapiro would have for a high value guy
because he's not he doesn't have his
baby like okay I agree I agree people
will argue about the definition forever
but to have a debate we have to have a
starting definition it's on point he
doesn't have this on point he's not he's
not like he's not going to church all
right influence ambition conviction
strong will four qualities that are
Baseline that can be found throughout
all of high value men even evil men but
the problem okay so how do you measure
and let's talk about this as a group
class how do we measure influence
ambition convictions and strong will
because I think the issue is when we
don't use money how do we measure it how
do we measure influence
influence could be for example in a
business environment you can be
influential to your workers and be a
leader to them and be high value from
your community it doesn't have to be
unlike the world Spectrum but you're
still high value influential management
yeah but you see the issue even us
talking about it we've had like so many
different yeah dog every day right so to
him he's not necessarily a high value
guy so he's what is synagogue has to do
with high value that's like that's the
way that other people would Define it
wait
[Music]
um
actually has a definition of what a high
value man is wait he does yeah because
he wouldn't be able to measure someone
and say they're not high value if you
don't have a metric that you're
measuring oh because if you're saying
Ben isn't high value then he has seven
what is the metric that's why he's not
telling us here yeah yeah
value is not subjective when we talk
about value talking about some sort of
Exchange in a market no no values
usually what are people willing to do or
give for a certain thing he's not it's
not defined by this one if one man is on
an island
no this one over your head it's the idea
of being high value but see when you say
you're not gonna get it like the whole
point of having these conversations is
you have to like
you have to bring it like say it in a
way that people are going to understand
it you can't just call them idiots and
say they're oh you're not going to get
it diminishing return like you have you
have to say it in a way that people will
understand
um in my opinion anyway I think this is
like a defense mechanism when you
flipped things like this you just don't
know and you just mask it this way and
flip it so
um there are multiple factors that can
make someone high value when a person
excels in any of those factors they can
be high value
right okay so
we're having such a disconnect in the in
the red pill guys like what what is a
high value yeah being high value and if
it was anybody else on the show you guys
would be roasting them okay so if we're
gonna go down the route if it's
character someone said character morals
belief money attitude or I'll hear all
the things that make you high value if
we're gonna do character how do we
measure character and this is where like
the Trad cons come in and then they'll
say well a real high value man they'll
give like their monologues right so
they'll say well real value man is
character a real high value men does
this this this this and this but a lot
of times it's tough we can't like
measure for the for the conversation
if any of the girls come here because
you give this the girls all the time she
goes high value men need to have a
premarital contract before marriage I
think I'm a 10. it's like why because
I'm so special and blah blah blah you're
not special Brandon Carter as an example
we can use any exam any single example
you want you could be the 500 pound guy
who just does Esports or can be like
Brandon Carter or the top G and one of
those guys the thing still applies all
right look look are you better off are
you better off without
like me I've defined it this is what I
think makes you high value you might
have a different take on you my role you
might have a different take on it I've
defined it thank you Oregon Trails 44
for the super my interpretation off what
you said if you want to get these things
and it makes sense to me those things
that you listed but I'm seeing here that
everyone here kind of has a hot
different interpretation but that's not
true all four of us probably roughly
agree with my value no we don't the
three of us probably Ben Shapiro said
you you said you have high value I don't
think like some amount of like physical
fitness we all agree that that's
decently valuable correct on some level
I don't think you need morals to be a
high value man
because I think that
because I think that evil men can be
high value
cool because are we going to say that
was the guy in North Korea that he's not
a high value man
[Music]
ends up being subjective so I kind of
get what Rolo is saying here because
he's saying whatever I say you guys if
you're gonna argue yeah you're gonna
have your own but everyone and it's
their own definition yeah and it's hard
because I could hear myself like arguing
with myself because every time I say
something it's like I'll think of a way
to yeah yeah okay having some amount of
like social status so you've got the
attention of a lot of people you're
influential we all agree on that right
having some amount of
okay that's a way that's a way to phrase
it because that would work for good or
bad the status and influence actual
success right you have freedom to take
of your family retire if you want to
even at an early age we all agree with
that right okay and having some level of
success with your family and friends
right we all we all roughly agree on
that right okay if you have those four
things in check you're probably a high
value man no it's more than that see
here's what he's saying I
I'm worth it because for me in my head
value is way more than that to you what
that might be important but to me it's
not that's not everything what's the
part what's a key component missing from
what I said it's a high value guy the
guy that marries somebody from a foreign
country brings you over here so she can
get citizenship because that's your
family Dynamic my family Dynamic is
different than that yeah see now you're
going personal yeah and that's the thing
like you can't attack
like what he did but that's not doesn't
have anything to do with the argument
that's the thing he's just defending
himself in a weird way
um a high value man is a man who's been
openly respected and accepted by his
male peers and is held as an example for
others in his respective culture I'm
five coach I would say only people that
are comfortable with their evil side are
high value
does that make me high value or low was
Osama high value
[Music]
um
most influential men in history is the
prophet Muhammad he could fight was a
leader had multiple wives the best
character in filled his fulfilled his
mission
um after this debate someone needs to
stand up Myron fresh sneaker Rule and
make an official high value man
definition for the rest of the
manosphere without one we're going to
keep going in circles
um
the biggest issue with the topic is we
act as if it's binary high value or no
value it's as if medium value doesn't
exist mob boss is high value underboss
is medium value
value exactly it's going to depend on on
the person if I'm in if I'm in a
heterosexual marriage for 27 years and
not in a polycule or some [__] like it's
like some people will say you're high
value because you do that people will
say roller you can't be red pill because
you're married you can't be married
because you're red pill okay and
suddenly I'm blue pill because I am
actually in a relationship where it's
like clothes on her and clothes on here
on on her end and close on my end but if
I go they've been arguing about the
definition and we have a similar general
idea but Destiny and sneaka won't frame
it for the sake of moving the discussion
forward when I talk to the top G or I
talk to somebody who's like in an open
relationship is that guy high value
because of that I'm not this is not a
judgment call I'm just saying that the
definition is going to be different even
if you have all those things even each
one of those things that you just
mentioned is still uh it's still subject
to the context I agree with what you
said Destiny what I'm saying is that
from within each one of those attributes
people are going to have something
something wildly different and you know
what they're going to do they're going
to use that for blog fodder and topics
to go and do you know quick hit videos
on because they just want you know click
through right for something I do agree
like no matter what he says people are
going to argue with but if you but
you're right too if Ben Shapiro is not a
high value man then you have to define
it
not
say it while Goa roll was saying here
he's put out the tweet as a way of
um encouraging discussion around being a
high value man he wasn't really trying
to frame and say what a high value man
is for himself because what he's saying
is is subjective depending on the nature
of the person he has a definition of
what high value men is which he should
have just said in that conversation yeah
to stop the dragging on what's happening
right now right but what you're saying
is it's actually subjective according to
like why a high value men might be to me
might be different to you because of
culture influences morals and all that
stuff right into it so I think that's
why it's just that's what they're just
arguing up on here yeah you know what
I think he is afraid to be judged of his
definition of a high value man and to be
classified as a blue pill not not as a
red pill no I don't think that's it I
think he just knows no matter what he
says because that's exactly what
happened on the stream that we did was
we I tried to say okay we all agree this
is a high value man and I listed Kevin
Samuels like this is what Kevin Samuels
used to say and then the Christians were
like no that's not a high value man and
then it's like you you just talk in
circles but yeah could say it's someone
that males want to be friend with and
then women want to associate with and
it's take it easy
oh wait
um okay I have a
an answer no someone someone messaged me
something okay
description all right the term high
value is often considered subjective
because I think this is something Rolo
wrote
um okay wait let me wait
all right the term high value is often
considered subjective because it relies
um
okay oh this is from torch I wasn't sure
if you wanted to tell me to tell you go
follow torsha um she sent me this all
right I think Rolo wrote this or maybe
torsha did she didn't say yet okay the
term high value is often considered
subjective because it relies on
no no what okay
oh Tori okay
okay all right I'm gonna read it one
more time sorry guys the term high value
man is often considered subjective
because it relies on individual
preferences cultural norms and personal
values what one person finds attractive
or value made different from another
person's perspective therefore it is
challenging to establish an objective
definition of a high value man that
applies universally what is what is
objective versus subjective a subjective
term refers to something that is based
on personal opinions perspectives
experiences varying from person to
person it is influenced by uh in it is
influenced by individual interpretation
and cannot be measured or proven
universally
objective refers to something that is
based on factual information independent
of personal opinions or biases it is not
influenced by individuals perspectives
and can be measures observed or verified
in a consistent reliable manner
objective information is generally
considered to be universally true or
valid it is based on tangible evidence
and standards why do we use them
subjective words subjective words are
necessary to capture the diversity of
The Human Experience beliefs and
perspective preferences allowing for
individuals expression and acknowledging
um
and acknowledging okay
and considered to be all right so why oh
okay the way this is
acknowledging the complexity of the
human what would you say
um the human perception subjective terms
like taste and Beauty oh that's an
interesting so subjective terms like
taste and Beauty can be influenced by
objective factors such as ingredients
cooking techniques or symmetry but
personal preferences
um
ultimately shape the subjective
perception while certain objective
measures exist individual preference and
cultural influences play a significant
role in determining attractiveness
um Can a subjective term have objective
truths to it while subjective terms are
primarily influenced by people's
opinions and perspectives they can still
be informed by a certain criteria or
standards
oh um Tori wrote it and okay high value
man is a term itself that refers to a
man who possesses certain desirable
traits qualities are accomplishments
that make him attractive to potential
Partners however the definition of a
high value man can vary greatly
depending on an individual perspectives
and cultural context what one person
considers a high value might not be the
same for someone else some common
characteristics associated with the
concept include Fitness financial
success confidence ambition social
status leadership abilities on a family
man however those traits are not
universally agreed upon as indicators of
high value and different individuals may
prioritize different qualities that is
why Rolo's tweet gained the traction is
dead it's not the first time this high
value man debate has been questioned
that is the point of the post
that makes sense yeah makes sense okay
women oh go ahead
at least he has like uh the five things
uh that we've been going through since
the beginning of the debate
um he stated them clearly which are like
uh yeah Fitness and whatever
sneaker is on a journey to learn the
whole Islam high value man is definitely
about morality Pearl so it's done there
because high value men meet positive and
good not evil and Jesus and Muhammad are
high value God fearing is high value but
then the question you get is everyone
has a different morality like that's the
issue you're gonna get yeah like like
would would the the
um Muhammad be high value to Catholics
do you know what I mean like then all
the Christian people are going to argue
with each other and that's why it's like
for everyone there's no been like one
person that the world has ever agreed on
never been one person
um Glenn Lawrence I'm about to roast
them let me know if you want to hop on
maybe uh these shoes we're gonna they
are all the guests here yeah oh they're
all here okay yeah we got it we gotta
end soon but I do want to get him on
because this guy was like an ex-pastor
or something I think I I just he hopped
out of stream the other day so if we say
what is a high value woman
you tell me man it's like again it's a
this is the definition and you're going
to get in the same issue with high value
women
and that's why like my show is more like
conversations it's not really like
debate because a lot of the stuff we
talk about is like everyone's personal
experience
um okay
Tori I'm gonna read this I hope I hope
you're allowing me to but I'm guessing
Okay the reason Rolo is frustrated
because they are focusing on what is
Right remember they always apply a moral
agenda
that's true because they're they're
trying to focus on like what's right and
what's wrong
I don't agree I think you just asked the
question they're saying what is your
definition of high value and he won't
answer he won't answer and obviously it
matters because roller is one of the I
would say what founding pillars of the
rest yeah so his High valley definition
has a low of weight in terms of why you
consider super high value so you should
have just stated this high value thing
and then put it out there first but I
think I think the problem is Rolo like
views himself like imagine you're you're
a scientist
and people are saying like what
I'm trying to think of an equivalent but
it's basically they're asking a
scientist
um for like what what is a high value
man but he he just looks at everything
as like data stats numbers and since
that's a subjective measure it's like he
can't answer and give his personal
opinion no but even science scientists
come to conclusions well so he should
have had a conclusion why did he
conclude high value was
[Music]
because because he has a definition
because he's measuring you're right
because he said because he said Ben
Shapiro isn't so he has to have a
definition yo so what what is this
metric just for him and was like you
know
and then if people are going to
scrutinize whatever you say anyways yeah
yeah it's the internet
except me I really I receive no scrutiny
none huh
why are you so obsessed with me just
like your wheels this is your chance to
steamroll I don't think you understand
why wheelhouse is
okay wait wait
they think Rolo is trying to avoid
defining it but he's explaining it's
subjective they think it's what a woman
what is a woman conversation but it's
but that's different
um a woman who is an adult female with
two X chromosomes huh
okay about you women dude I keep in fact
if anything I said there's no such thing
as a quality woman because it's an ideal
that guys have in their heads there's no
such thing as a quality woman no such
thing as a quality woman because guys
have this I the quality woman is an idea
someone said a high value man
um who stops being a boy so he can get
the job done through money uh Speech
strength man in Africa hunts and feeds
his tribe a man in USA Works nine to
five and plays music and pays his bills
Pearl why why did you take down the
stream with Rolo there were things
spoken about
um
yeah we had uh yeah
um if we talk about objective value it's
probably six foot six six figures six
inches
maybe we could talk about that when I
get there yeah but it's like did all the
world leaders have six inches
it's like we could go all day
uh someone said if it's subjective we
kind of have a debate I don't that's not
right either I feel like any opinion is
Up For Debate uh it should be able to
defend your position and I think I don't
think Royal was prepared to defend his
uh position on this on this case
but the thing is is this is like when
you're building a relationship or when
you have this idea in your head you want
to know why guys get into so much
[__] trouble in their marriages it's
because of that ideal because every
every guy who ever got married thought
that she was the best [__] thing in
the world otherwise he wouldn't got
married to her and until he gets across
a divorce ticket yeah I actually agree
there's no such thing as a quality woman
or a good woman there's women that prove
to be quality later on but I I think
like when you choose you can like
there's
better draft picks and worse draft picks
but there's no guarantee
it's for me I have another I see things
differently okay you know some I'll give
you a context for example this woman yes
she was very liberate and everything but
she came to a realization that it's time
to commit to a man maybe she'll serve
him better than a very conservative that
just switches positions afterwards
because for example the first one
learned the lesson the hard way right
but that kind of supports my point that
you don't know which one's going to be
the right like you don't there's no
right woman there's good pics and bad
like there's girl like you know if a
girl has a sleeve of tattoos that's
probably a worse Choice like typically
yeah but you're never really Gonna Know
that's a growth uh both of like both
sides think
um they have to grow together so they
can and have that um to be like they
want to move forward in a good direction
that's that's the thing if it's not this
way then it's going to be a bad draw but
either way well from her now she's a
[__] evil it's back home whenever you
don't you genuinely don't think that
there's quality women in the world I
don't think I think that there are there
are women who have different attributes
than others that match very well with uh
with guys sure they're good clicks of
course
the thing is it's like the idea of the
quality woman is an ideal that guys have
that gets them into a lot of trouble
that's why they're in love with the
ideal not the actual Tori says no man
um has ever successfully vetted a woman
but there aren't high value women
I was saying
there aren't high value men and there
aren't high value women okay it's it's
it it just depends on who we're talking
about I don't know what the hell he's
talking about
I don't even know what the [__] we're
it is not like uh disagree with the
whole red pill idea of like having he
said there is no such thing as high
volume and or like I have a high value
Woman as a standard but like the whole
red pill concept is there is a high
value woman and a high value man no most
guys will say hi well
it's hard it's subjective too that's the
problem but like I I know Myron says
that high value women have to be
selected by high value men
so you can't be a high value woman
unless you're selected by a high value
man I disagree with with what he says
how else would you be a high value woman
it's according to uh the red pill
what I've seen and what I've read they
say that high value women are women that
are at a certain level of beauty at a
certain level of the Purity they have
low body count yeah they're right right
but they like typically that's what high
value men like go for
like you can't get in the door with high
value man if you're not beautiful but
just because you're beautiful that
doesn't make you a high value woman you
know I mean so like how how do we it's
like who's a winner and who's a loser
when it comes to women the women that
get picked so how can you be a high
value woman if don't pick two
but don't you think if a woman just kept
herself at a certain standards she would
be a high value oh yeah she's selected
or not no I think then like men would
pick like because when you use high
value it's like the top person like
it's like the top percentage like
there's not like it's what five ten
percent of women so I I think most like
the top five ten percent of women get
picked usually before 25 typically
um because you're the top women want to
be picked before 25.
models as high value women like if
they're picked by high value men I think
if they have motherly like traits
um but typically if they don't they'll
get divorced
but like for the the selection current
process if they're got if they are
selected for example by a CEO of I don't
know a certain company and he selected a
model from the the field would you uh
consider her high value or not
if she stays married yeah
okay
there are things Muhammad Jesus and
Prophets all said fear God we're common
value between that so high value is a
morality and good character value chain
uh William um value changes based on
region often in North Dakota a man with
a crurgy uh I don't know I'm sorry a
good income and a truck is a high value
regardless of outfit that is very
different than Miami and Houston
um a lord Commander president isn't
normally an influence-based position
that president has high value but does
the president's ear make you high value
is Obama's best friend high value is
Obama's best friend and others friends
high value by association oh gosh
now you know what it is Destiny so you
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about on any of this and I'm surprised
because you write about this all the
time you wrote a whole book about it
people they really respect it and I have
no idea you guys might be confused
because I'm the one that says there's no
such thing as a high value woman a woman
has a woman gets her value directly from
a man that she gets in a relationship
with because all women have value but
not all men have value all women don't
have the same value
well don't even think about you know
that's not true if I give you one with
100 bodies and a woman with zero bodies
might give you one that's 500 pounds so
yeah I think okay here's my thing
because I've said this one okay wait
um this is from
uh Rola wrote this the quality woman is
defined by how well she fits a man's
conditioned ideal
oh so again he's saying it's subjective
Good Luck Chuck laminated in last week's
hyenas
um and that after a certain age all
women are alpha widows or progressively
lose the idealization of embodying the
quality woman well I understand that's a
frustration there's an eerily similar
tone they use when they be moan the lack
of quality women in the world that
Echoes women's when they ask what
happened to all the real men the only
difference in being that in girl world a
woman is entitled to a real man
irrespective of her own quality while
man is less of a man for the complaints
for lacking those qualities
poor
be calm and women are I know everybody
there are some women that are better
than others of course but all women have
value to some level but not all men have
value because men have to build their
[__] up so what I'm saying is that a
high value woman that doesn't even try
value woman gets her value from being
with a high value man I don't even think
that's true all men have values metric
of success for a female is being able to
get the best man that they can get and
men can build and do things in places
like China where you have where you're
limited to the many children what do
they do they offer boys because they can
go out and work and [__] get jobs and
[__] and do things around the [__]
house or whatever right [__] 1980s
one wild one child policy hasn't been
around since the mid 90s dude when it
was it was grossly favoring the birth of
boys because you could do more with boys
with women just the idea like this that
was a prescription and now and now
they're now they're facing the
consequences of that well so is Japan
that's a super homologous I thought it
was
name was like passed to a boy
like carry on your family that's what I
thought it was but but I don't know
maybe okay you're using China but let's
be honest here why does it say women and
children off the boat first we're not
men
women
no yeah it's a chivalry thing but but
why is that because if you have 100
women and one guy you can still continue
Society if you have 100 men and one
woman we're [__] women are vulnerable
sex and men are the Disposable sex
that's why women have value inherently
so what I'm saying is this
ever since every woman has value from it
to be high value she's got to be able to
lock down a high value guide there's a
reason why women take a Man's last name
and not the other way around women when
they meet each other and hug the first
thing they ask typically is oh do you
have a man do you have a relationship
sorry about your kids Etc when two men
meet what do they do shake hands what do
you do for a living men are just not
creating value women are judged on
creating children typically now are
there some women out there that chase
success at making money whatever sure
but that is not the main goal of a
female the main goal of a female from a
biological sense is to procreate for a
woman to procreate she's got to be with
a man typically they want the best guy
for a man of procreate he's got to
create excess resources to be able to
attract that woman so what we bring to
the table is different and what I was
already with any of that but there are
high value women and they're probably a
high value I think homes only high five
she could lock down a high value guy
that's my take okay well at least you
have a definition yeah that's my
definition on it which again I see all
of us here at the table have different
opinions which is great but that's
okay he's saying there's no high value
women
was Queen Elizabeth the high value oh
God no no I'm talking about someone
who's born into wealth born into royalty
does that no makeup blessing that was a
really good point and I I don't know
okay I don't really have a good answer
we'll leave it to the chat yeah yeah
I'm I'm sorry Chad I take on it like
with a high value man a high value
they're saying no no no okay maybe
what you want me to stay is it do you
think Queen Elizabeth is a high value
woman
she has to be like yeah what he's saying
no
yeah
come on man
uh
you might you you you're no no no guys
let me look at this when when she got
married her husband gave up her his
titles to take her Legacy helping you
get married how old was she then
yeah it was cool then back then then
cool but now she ain't no no but as a
whole like we can call Gandhi high value
in terms of like there's a whole it's
Queen Elizabeth no high value is is that
what we're saying here
I would say she is she's born into a
royalty I mean that's that's where I
don't I disagree with the fact there are
women I mean they just don't have value
unless until they're locked by a high
value like you cannot deny royalty don't
you
so subjective very okay let's work with
what it's not a high value woman that's
a low body count who is uh you know a a
girl from the Amish Dutch Country in
Pennsylvania who's never you know known
another man doesn't have any social
media I mean there's there's a lot of
ways we can go with this but again it's
those are ideals okay
because ideals are what we strive for an
idealists deals are also what lead us
astray which is why this list is [__]
useful
ideals lead you into a better life
that's the whole point of an ideal it's
the best version of yourself you're
never going to be the best version of
yourself but the path to being the best
version of yourself every guy who ever
thought he found his [__] soulmate
who ended up on the opposite side of the
[__] divorce table from her had a
[__] ideal about that woman yeah I
agree with that I've interviewed you
watch some of these interviews blessing
some of these guys were in love every
man that dies happily surrounded by his
family who had alone I know the Pastoral
scene with everybody Pearl Rollo tweeted
his definition of high value hours later
had luck but I can't well yeah we're
surrounded by his fan you know what you
know that like 90 of the like the
population of the United States doesn't
die like that they actually die in
assisted living and nobody knows about
it until the next morning okay as
opposed to you who's talking about dies
real fast
we're gonna go through this real fast um
all right so we got kid blue r b goes uh
roller Dodge into defining a high value
man is like the LGBT dodging what a
woman is feels like I'm watching
mouthwash documentary right now you're
the Grand Master of RP you're you out of
all people should be able to Define what
you can't Define high value mail but he
could Define us as douche nozzles all
right let me let me that's pretty funny
though uh microsu says Myron you're my
guy but you're giving uh Rolo and out
let him stand on the Cherry standing on
so he can continue to hang himself with
his food I know you really want to
defend him
you know you based a lot of the show
around that book but like bro he's
making absolutely no sense here's the
thing everyone is interpreting it
different obviously I have my take on it
roll it has this take he doesn't have a
tank right we all have different
textures he doesn't have a tape kill it
still a take okay
would be all laughing and roasting the
fight right so interesting I watched
this last night and I heard it
completely different today
see what I mean like like I watched it
last night and I had a completely
different
yeah okay so if a woman came out here
like what makes a woman high value she's
like well if she's like if she's in her
moment and if she's girl bossing it up
as hard as she can that's a high value
woman like we would be roasted that's
the same argument he's making right now
what I'm saying that's not this no he's
saying it's it depends on the call I
understand oranges
that's the problem with all this [__] is
like you don't even understand the
nature of the Tweet that's why the
question you can't answer it ask if it's
advice it's not it's a joke it's not the
minute because the minute because okay
here's the thing here's what let me just
let me just let me go let me give you a
high value matter high value man goes
and [__] as many chicks as he possibly
can any guard any all as many women as
possible and he [__] finds one little
needle in the haystack and he wipes up
that girl because she happens to have a
no body count she's like a hundred
percent in love with him and I mean I
can go and rattle off all these extremes
and you know who's going to disagree
with me every guy in [__] daily wires
say what you really think don't say it
ironically say what you believe
what I'm saying is what I believe here
okay this is the whole thing is because
he believes it's subjective
that's what he's saying
I really don't think so because if he
but then he wouldn't have said the bench
Ben is there he wouldn't classify it
um
it's your definition of what it is
someone says Humanity doesn't get to
determine what is valuable God gets to
determine what is valuable
um if humans do it then it's always
subjective but then it's like okay what
God then you're going back in circles
like what yeah
but
but for me now it has to just be
according to a common social point of
view it doesn't have to be accurate 100
but at least a ground to start from
not a high value man so you must be
comparing him to some standard in your
head you said basis is not a high value
man you said Elon Musk is not a high
volume so there's some standard here
yeah and Destiny made a point there
they're not matching up he mentioned his
uh closed relationship as uh like
something valuable to him so something
like that would pay high value for him
as well that's why I said he could have
um been like feared of like uh
considered as a blue pill if he said for
example high value he's being just uh
you know standard right well let's let's
all you would have to do is look at
their personal life so you could
understand this again do I have time to
go into uh enumerate all that no I don't
but if you go and you look at what
they're doing like all right Taurus just
says he said Ben isn't because when they
asked for Roller's opinion that's
subjective people don't understand
Rolo's writing iron rule number three is
a woman who makes you wait for sex the
sex was not for worth the wait what do
people think of that it means
validational versus transactional
okay okay look let's just use Elon Musk
for a sec for a second here let's use
Ben Shapiro that was a good example Ben
Shapiro we can look at Ben Shapiro how
did he meet his wife do you know how he
met his wife what do they close the
range right was it an arranged or family
friends I don't know well basically what
Ben Shapiro did was he he wore this
chick down over the course of God knows
like three or four months right he would
he would meet the definition of stalking
and being a creeper on the if he wasn't
Ben Shapiro right if he didn't have this
his background three to four months what
does that mean basically he he wore her
down is what he did and he's very proud
of that fact so that's that's one thing
he's saying without saying that high
value men doesn't want women down
he's pretty much saying it because he's
saying yeah he did that uh disqualifies
him uh because the high value meant like
so high volume man is supposed to just
get that girl straight up yeah so he's
he doesn't chase women yeah so he's
saying it like that would if he said
high value men don't chase women it
would have been easier it would have I
mean you could argue with it still right
some people would agree or disagree but
like his thinking at least makes sense
yeah
when somebody asks you what is X and
then you go well it's X you're not
really answering the question you've
done this like three times what when you
say wore her down over three to four
months what does that mean do they date
did he see her after school what that
means is he kept he was persistent he
just kept wearing her down
bro that's ridiculous man
I will send you I will send you the
[__] I will send you the video I will
send you the video okay Jesus
all right you guys should view your
columns more often it's cute
okay
and you should send your only fan girls
to come at me to uh debate me in your
proxy next time you're asking the video
right now and you can't even except next
time please find the girl who actually
puts lenses in her glasses a little
weird you're so triggered dude are you
okay not very rational I think uh he
should his six months
because I would consider Ben Shapiro
high value guy I would yes no everybody
would obviously but but you disagree
with things on it with the Grand Master
The Godfather it's not it's not about
saying don't F her if she makes you wait
but people took that without reading the
book and said its advice the book
explains it's about Discerning who wants
you and who wants to use you everything
they say they debate now is just
emotional because they can't grasp with
Concept they haven't read his work
that's what tors great great granddaddy
sorry Tori
would you would you agree with his uh
outlook on women
uh where Ben Shapiro's outlook on female
on women yeah your Ben Shapiro has
literally come at you for exactly this
for everything that these that these
guys are talking about he's coming at
you for exactly the same thing yeah so
you guys did a full show on this no no
for sure I disagree with him on uh as
far as like the female stuff like oh
yeah that like having sexual experience
isn't is like bad for you like
Christians who follow Jesus even
becoming a martyr and stand for God who
gives his will freely is
um to freely choose their fate our high
value through Jesus you see there's
another definition he was trying to say
um but I think objectively speaking from
the things that I listed as far as what
I think makes a guy high value he has
all those things now he's limited on his
knowledge of females for sure right
because I think he only got with one
girl and you know she comes from a
certain fan type she comes from a family
and a certain family I don't want to say
because we're on YouTube but um
that set her up to be a girl that would
be to his liking but the point I'm
trying to make is I think Benjamin is a
high value guy but I don't agree with
the stances on women everyone if you use
God as the basis for what makes a high
value man please be careful of the
youthiforo dilemma is it good because
God said it was or was it good because
God where was it good already and God
liked it same thing with with Stephen
Crowder right now you guys are just
talking about Crowder not too long ago
like like right up until he got this
divorce and all this stuff started
coming out in Kansas songs
I think they're high value guys like
Crowder and I was gonna say like for
roller seems like a low of wise like uh
defining high value has a lot to do with
the type of woman you get
uh first off he was addressing like
um Ben Shapiro what he had to do to get
his wife now he's on the crowded
situation I think is his definition is
something to do with like uh the type of
woman your girl pretty much me but then
then again I think it contradicts the
point that does it a woman validate why
you are high value I thought it's the
other way around yeah that's right sorry
a woman validate why a man is a high
value or is it the other way around
because the way is making you see me is
that like yo you're a high value men but
it's determined by the women yeah so
that's the woman
some people think so like some people
think it's the like the women or the
selectors I don't know if I necessarily
agreed with that but wait they say
overall they keep attacking him for not
defining it but he did it's just not
objective red pill isn't a religion so
if someone uses red pill but follows God
his definition will depend on his life
red pill has objective truth but you
take what applies to you
um
based on what they've accomplished in
life but I don't agree with their
standpoints that if he disagrees with
them then they
foreign
was a high value man
um Don bringer um there's an old saying
that puts three things in Balance power
influence and money any um one of them
attract others let's use the examples of
Jesus Gandhi even though they didn't
have money
um supports supplied it I have no
[__] point but there's no point for
either one of you to be on this [__]
show quite honestly Dumbledore has
spoken because here's the thing the the
traditional conservative beliefs don't
necessarily work in today's sexual
Marketplace when it comes to dealing
with women no we agree but that's the
reason he thinks bench I don't
understand why Cinco can't be on the
show
you get to dictate who's on the internet
okay feels a high Valley because he
disagreed with you Glenn Lawrence
high value is subjective to the culture
that man is in but regardless there are
basic principles that cross all cultures
being a man of status influence and
power and authority are characteristic
so Glenn how would you measure that
in relationships
sometimes what I'm saying is that that
well yes I would actually agree with
that simply okay Tori oh
overall snico and Destiny aren't
listening Rolo isn't wrong and Myron was
right but hesitated because Destiny just
steamrolls and roasts Rolo he does do
that that's what a lot of people on the
left will do like personal attacks but
then Rolo started doing it too so it's
like if you guys are just personally
attacking each other what does that have
to do with the conversation because like
and I think Rolo personally attacked him
first I think he did with the glasses
okay
does Ben Shapiro the way his life what
his disagreement with you does that and
then at least in some way diminish him
as a high value man no we can disagree I
disagree I'm asking Myron I mean because
it's Myron who says he always I value
God but like subscribe that he disagrees
from the traditional relations
like money muscles in game okay
it's the it's the uh it's the female
aspect of what what makes a high value
guy right if he disagrees with what he's
not disagree with it he just said that
he's high value
he said he's high value but except for
that one part where he's saying you know
what I disagree with his his Outlook
when it comes to like women and how best
to go about like forming relationships
or whatever the sex whatever it is yeah
I think he's a high value guy but I
disagree with his notion on how to deal
with women he's not [__] 50. he's not
[__] 50 guy or 50 50 women yeah he's
not he's not he's against that which I
think is dated you know what I mean
again like I said before I think a guy
could be have be traditionally
conservative but I'd not agree I don't
necessarily have to agree with someone's
viewpoints on how they deal with females
for me to see them as high value because
I think he accomplishes all the things
that I mentioned on my list of what I
think makes it a high value and so and
so what you're doing is you're saying
that high value is these accomplishments
correct I'm interpreting it yeah that's
how I interpret it which obviously
everyone here at the panel has a
different
effects which is which is we don't
really have a different I feel like I
definitely I know you're pretty aligned
at the table Yeah well that's three yeah
but I mean again we're looking at things
differently in general okay because you
guys don't agree I agree with his tweet
if you want to become high value in the
quickest amount of time you can't agree
with it if he doesn't even Define it you
can't agree with him if you don't even
know what his definition is but I just
does he agree with it okay this is
I I think she said I could read this
okay I think um they've been laughing
they were no Destiny did it first they
were laughing and being condescending
first and roller reacted this is proof
whatever whoever stays calm appears to
win but pay attention
[Music]
they aligned because Destiny is applying
a moral agenda
because they're talking about what's
right and what's wrong and and uh Rolo
is trying to talk about what is
that kind of makes sense because they're
both saying like like life is not
meaningful without kids like that's
that's not that's like a moral judgment
where where Rolla was saying it depends
on the culture you're in so it's like
they're saying it's like a moral thing
and Rolo's saying no it depends on the
culture you're in but I think the more
cultures agrees
um how kids are important in a person's
life don't you think so yeah but like
then we go back to George Washington
High value no he's still high value even
without the kids but that's why I think
they're saying like life is Meaningful
is not meaningful without kids what was
George Washington's life not meaningful
but this is
again comes
to so we come in high value yeah and
they started because of the steps to
becoming high value he said avoid kids
but like after becoming high value you
can have kids yeah it's kind of yeah
I'm falling over your head because you
guys are thinking about one point what's
that to me that's it we won't even have
a second me but that's okay I think we
Tori says kids are a Disney Fantasy
remember only 40 of men reproduce
are women not meaningful if they can't
reproduce
great question I'm just going to keep
his definition is correct
yeah he knows his definition yeah
exactly I don't even matter just like
people that have high value
um we got here Viking Paradigm ignoring
the context talking over interrupting ad
hominem's goal post shifting claiming
it's advice when it's not it's easy to
see who's trying to control their
viewers and who's not and easy to see
who lost the debate here
that's a douche nozzle thing to say shut
up Viking man that's not very rational
of you uh life love value women aren't
so simple leave these RP dudes alone in
their zones of Stew responsibility
intelligence and discipline above all
and our talismans of happiness for most
people enjoy life grind and don't
glorify I agree I agree 100 and then uh
what else do we got here we got uh
the answer is a woman's value is not her
womb
foreign
I hope y'all don't let Rolo's weird uh
immigration comment fly by
immigration comment immigration I wish I
got enough of a discussions
[Music]
what am I talking about
I don't know okay all right what else
anything else uh up to you guys question
mark
Destiny said kids are value
oh so the answer
if a woman oh because then you would ask
that back when they say like
kids you say well then as a woman not
okay okay
100 if I wanted to learn how to become a
successful man I'd go to Rolo before
going to sneaker or destiny uh two grown
ass men who argue like teenage boys so
55 year old guy calling us douche
nozzles to someone who's like three
times younger that's a mature way to
argue damn
if that's your idea then okay wow shots
fired that's just what happened on the
show
y'all
I mean they notified we plugged him out
of the line yeah go back to Twitch
that's there's some advice that's some
real advice for you guys you guys have
no business
yeah he should have stayed calm yeah
it's still conversation everything
more than any other name and the chats I
reach out like whenever I stream which
is when I'm online and you're in there
more than me so calling us Twitter but
actually I'm banned on there I'm on
Rumble it's true he is in the chat a lot
he does
or on Twitter or on Twitter it's always
tweeting the online card then maybe get
off the internet a little bit and
chatting all day
douche nozzle it's a lot harder when
it's not just like 22 year old women
being ganged up on a podcast huh I'm
sorry rello I'll be happy to [__]
debate you dude on any topic you what we
are right now
you're talking about this one [__]
tweet is what you're talking about well
we were talking to the Godfather of red
pill trying and speaking of [__] and
speaking of [__] I kind of understand
what he's saying he's saying it is it is
subjective like that is his answer it is
subjective based on the culture that's
his answer
speaking of [__] super chats another
personal one
I mean and he did just refuse to answer
the whole debate and he just flips the
arguments based on attacking no but I
think it was because he was asked
personally like what he personally
thinks because they asked him that
question was a personal question because
he's
really good yeah the red pill so he is
influential and he all of all of these
debates come in Cycles it takes more
time to refute [__] than it does to
create it remember I refute blue pillars
and you create red pill content was that
not you on whatever podcast you want to
make yeah I like to support people that
go on to have a podcast all right thank
you very much thank you for at least
admitting it those are the only two
super chats I've sent my life if I'm
watching content I want to know if it's
red pill or not seems like you're
watching a lot more than you think you
are the program I've ever been on it's
insane you should get a tax credit for
like watching me
man
okay I thought you'd have a wrap let's
see you say usually things you guys
first of all I've thrown out this she's
wearing his car after the show first of
all
this challenge if you guys want to come
to Vegas come to Vegas we'll sit across
the table from each other you don't have
your [__] dog [__] podcast what are
you talking about come to Miami
I am coming to Miami next week I'm going
to be in Miami too that's so crazy
that's crazy guys by the way um you know
shows uh we're doing one Saturday then
we're done
um for like a month
uh because we're going to Miami and
we're going all over the U.S so there's
gonna be a lot of U.S content um but you
can tune into Canyon riches five days a
week when we're not here yeah we'll be
here next week you guys are so mean man
we're mean he called us douche nozzles
oh it's fine he's the grand wizard of
red pill so I can't go say anything
about that but I'm me now because I
think there's some super chat so wait
there's one uh the value of an
individual depends on the context the
red pill Community it seems that there
is a lot more interest in what makes you
high value when it comes to mating
strategies between men and women for not
having any arguments at all
bro I know you want to defend him
because the book is here on the table
but like bro that made no sense you guys
have not read the book you guys don't
know what the [__] bro you can't even
Define what high value man is why would
I read a book from a woman's value is
her womb and ability to produce off
strings for the majority of History
oh
I think that's true
but it's for the majority like there's
exceptions but we're talking about the
rule in general and like I think that's
kind of how we have to like Define it
because I no matter what we do there's
always going to be an exception but in
general the most like the like the
highest like most successful women were
the ones that got the best genes
so like I would say like a high value
woman is the one that can get the best
Gene slash resources
um because in a way if you get the
resources then you get the genes too
because it's like you had to get brain
power maybe physical stature to get
there so I think like throughout most of
History it had to be her womb
this like do you like we could say oh
maybe Queen Elizabeth is an exception or
whatever like Cleopatra like but we're
talking about the rule in general yes
the general if we SP we are speaking
about the general rule yes the woman's
ability to reproduce however I would add
some other things on top of this like
morals and values and yeah like the
family
uh oriented uh morals because being just
reproducing and being a bad mom or a
like a bad wife but I think I think you
had to get morals like well because in
the concubine no I mean not really you
know like no I think in general it's the
getting the best jeans and like the I
think in in general it's getting the
best genes and the best
um resources for the kids I think in
general for me I'll just say that it's
it's
is reproducing it's like even even if
you were to look at it from the highest
level which is like royalty right right
these are like the highest level of
humanity I guess because they kind of
get everything out front if even if you
are like a Queen Elizabeth you're not
really considered the high value unless
you produce an air right I was gonna
who's more high value a woman that has
15 children or a woman that has a child
with a king
yeah that's what I think too but then it
goes back to the best genes right
yes or um
jeans I'll say resources yeah stage like
the Manchester's associated with yeah
okay what if what no no I'm not gonna go
down this Rabbit Hole I'm not gonna do
the wave
um okay uh kids are tradcon God take
again subjective and are harmful to say
woman without a womb women are treated
like property we don't live in an old
order overall proof we live in a
generation red pill is becoming
mainstream is a problem because people
don't do the work we can't operate in
Old order that's harmful women that's
harmful women were traded if they
couldn't concede conceive a baby on
their wedding night
Ah that's harm
I mean is it true though
um
for the last half hour I've been trying
to explain to you this [__] to this [__]
to you you guys have no business being
in this [__] sphere to begin with
first of all
or until you're 64. and the reason why
is
that's another advice I would have given
to the good the good guy here Rolo
um I think if you take more of your
fatherly raw where he is right now you
can't get keep the red pill it should be
more of a fat Elementary mentorship role
because a lot of why he hasn't and even
the lack of respect which I say this is
because it's still an elder it's because
he doesn't really give respect to the
young young people or constructive
advice that's just my opinion anyways
you should take more of your fatherly
role yeah or even the way he presents
himself you know when you label yourself
as The Godfather you can he I don't
think he labels himself The Godfather I
just want to correct you he he doesn't
call himself that people call him that
okay but at least he identifies as The
Godfather I don't think he identify I
think people just call him that like
people call me the female Andrew Tate I
don't identify as that so it's different
but but I mean you stand for your ideas
no I mean I think a lot of us like
wanted mentorship and weren't really
like he didn't
seem to want to give it to us so
yeah that's the thing and he's like uh
interacting in a very weird way so if
you're something who wants someone who
wants respect just stand in a position
of uh wisdom if it makes sense we can't
operate in Old order that's harmful
women were traded if they couldn't
conceive a baby on wedding night because
you devolve into you want to know why
like when we talk nobody debates anymore
because you know why because it devolves
into this Middle School [__] can I
get a big up to Falcon blizz sack and
kings and queens YouTube channel so they
always shout out [__] just pearly
things and big up to beautiful just
pearly things thank you both of you are
but you guys are perfect yes you just
marry each other you can't call this
childish when you were the one who
started insulting I would just ask you a
question and then you said douche nozzle
now you're gonna go play the maturity
card
yeah yeah now I'm gonna play the mature
all right she says that was good
um all right you got to know the history
they're operating in Old order thinking
kids we have an ego of investment in
ideals that don't exist ideals are
Disney's fantasies that dilute us
that was a middle school argument
all right I mean this is not going
anywhere this was a great debate Edition
I mean it's very obvious that everyone
here has different takes which is great
I think that's good I'm not sure what
it's taken still but that's cool it's
different than ours we know that you
know what I mean so it is what it is uh
is there anything else Chris or um of
the okay uh Tori says people always want
to use kids for a moral argument men get
effed over in divorce
[Music]
um
I want to read it one more time I want
to read it you got to know the history
they're operating in Old order thinking
we have ego Investments and ideals that
don't exist ideals are Disney Fantasies
that delude us because kids
um
uh because people always use kids for a
moral argument men get effed over in
divorce Trad cons want control over who
comes to term and life
if men had rights
okay I really gotta go because we gotta
get ready for this show
um let me read the super chats
um
[Music]
the
if women is able to have a lot of kids I
guess you could say she is at least a
has at least has a high value womb
um Glenn Lawrence the only reason why
men put their life on the line is
defending women is her in defending
women is her reproductive ability to
reproduce
um that would be different tried cons or
undercomer for convert feminists okay
well we'll talk about that a different
day Tori
um what'd you think of the debate it was
interest ing it was really good wasn't
it it was a really good debate it was
interesting and but the thing I still
need the definition of a high value man
like a concrete one I don't think we'll
ever this is making my brain hurt a
little bit
um blessing you got any final thoughts
uh High Valley man is subjective it's
gonna depend on your social values or
how you erase your moralities all of
that stuff so I don't think there's
going to be a definition that comes and
applies to every single human being so
uh just just assume that for yourself
get your own definition of what high
value is high value men and women obey
God's rules being a father and a mother
creating a new generation
um for good instead of bad every new
generation is important
okay
okay guys um like the video on your way
out and tune in um I think there's a
dating show that just came out while we
were streaming check that out
um also we have a show tonight so make
sure you tune in um thank you so much
for coming thank you very much Pearl
that was amazing like the video on your
way out guys subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time